Hallo Leute, ich bin wieder am Start. Ich sollte übrigens mal den Titel, äh, vielleicht ändern. BG3, Akt 3.
Wo sollen die hin? Sollen wir hier bleiben?
Ja, ich habe das Game minimal gemoddet.
Ich zeige euch auch gleich warum.
Nichts Großes.
Es gibt ja auch noch nicht jetzt wahnsinnig viele
wirklich tiefgreifende Mods, die irgendwie zig neues Content, neue NPCs und so bringen.
Ein bisschen was habe ich gemoddet und zwar eine Sache, die mir extremst auf den Sack gegangen ist. Ich zeige euch das gleich.
Das musste ich modden. Es gibt einen Mod, glaube ich, der das Ganze ein bisschen
DnD ähnlicher macht.
Aber ansonsten,
das habe ich aber nicht installiert. Ich glaube das Game ist nicht darauf ausgelegt,
dass man so hier drauf guckt, weil sieht schon ziemlich detailarm aus alles, gell?
Sieht man ja auch normalerweise nicht. Normalerweise guckt man ja so drauf und dann fällt es nicht auf.
Da hinten dreht sich auch nichts und so. Oh, ich müsste mal wieder
eine lange Rast einlegen.
Müssen wir mal checken, Leute, ob die Lautstärke gut ist. Ich glaube es sollte passen, oder?
Ich glaube die ist ganz okay.
Wenn die Lautstärke zu leise ist, sagt gleich Bescheid. Ja, ich glaube, ich habe es jetzt auf irgendwie auf knapp 30 gestellt. Das war das letzte Mal auch.
Ja, wo sind wir stehen geblieben? Also das letzte Mal, wo ich gestreamt habe, da war ich
Ende Akt 2. Da haben wir, glaube ich, diesen Sha-Tempel gemacht.
Und heute gucken wir uns Akt 3 an. Das ist ziemlich frisch. Start Akt 3. So,
weiß ich,
drei, vier Stunden in. Aber ich meine, ihr seht es an der Map. Ich habe im Prinzip aus der Map aufgedeckt. Also
Mainstory und so. Da hat es ja noch nichts getan. Diesen komischen Zirkus habe ich schon gemacht, aber der ist jetzt nicht sonderlich spannend gewesen. Da hat man nichts verpasst.
Und ich werde auch mal gucken. Ich werde jetzt erst mal ein bisschen alle Sidequests abgrasen, bevor ich Mainquests mache. Und mal gucken.
Mal gucken, was es sonst noch so gibt in Akt 3. Was man ja hört von Akt 3 ist, dass Akt 3 im Vergleich
ups, ja, passt auch irgendwie, dass Akt 3 im Vergleich zu Akt 1 und 2 ein bisschen
nachlässt.
Ich habe es bisher noch nicht so großartig gemerkt. So ein paar Dialogoptionen waren vielleicht ein bisschen sehr abrupt.
Und
ich hatte einmal den Bug,
dass Gale nicht mehr Fast Travelen konnte.
Der war einfach broken. Den habe ich angeklickt, bin hier auf die Map und es ging nichts mehr.
Das war komplett kaputt. Man musste Gale killen und wiederbeleben. Dann hat es funktioniert. Keine Ahnung warum.
Aber ansonsten hatte ich nicht komische,
chromatische, komische Bugs.
Ja, mal gucken. So.
Da waren wir mal. Ach ja, und eine Änderung gibt es in meiner Party.
Shadowheart. Shadowheart ist jetzt ein,
man sieht das hier glaube ich, hier,
ist jetzt kein
Edgy, Emo, Schal, Trickster-Cleric mehr, sondern ein, so wie sich das gehört,
ein
Light-Cleric of,
sieht man die Gottheit hier irgendwie, ist Selune. Selune? Selune.
Oder wie der Franzose wahrscheinlich sagen würde,
Selune. Keine Ahnung.
Passt auch zur Story ganz gut. Und sie hat grauer Haaren jetzt, anstatt schwarzer Haaren.
Da bin ich mir ehrlich gesagt nicht ganz sicher, ob das ein Bug ist, weil hier im
Avatar-Bild
hat sie noch schwarze Haaren, hier hat sie weiße Haaren. Also es hätte storymäßig ganz gut gepasst, dass sie weiße Haare bekommt.
Aber, also ich bin mir nicht sicher, was der Bug ist. Entweder ist das Avatar-Bild der Bug,
oder die Anzeige in-game der Bug.
Man weiß es nicht so genau.
Oh, was ist denn? So, wieder da.
Gibt kein neues Avatar-Bild. Doch, gibt es.
Habe ich auch schon gesehen. Ich habe Leute gesehen, die hatten ein Avatar-Bild von Shadowheart mit weißen Haaren. Keine Ahnung.
Letztendlich, wen, Jungs? Ich zeige euch, also bei dir, ja. Ja, ne, bei mir gibt es irgendwie kein neues Avatar-Bild.
Vielleicht ist es auch erst bei Level Up, aber Level Up, naja, Level Up dauert noch ein bisschen.
Mein Avatar, äh, mein übrigens, mein Inventar sieht wieder
exquisite aus.
Ja, so, eine Sache kann ich euch jetzt noch erzählen zu den Mods. Ich habe nur eine kleine Sache gemoddet, und zwar,
hört mal,
Gale.
Gale sieht bei mir eigentlich ganz nice aus jetzt, so wie man sich das bei einem Wizard vorstellt, ja.
Moment, Gale, Gale, komm mal her, so.
Gale, perfekt, so, komm. Gale sieht, Gale sieht ja eigentlich ganz nice
Wizard-mäßig aus, ja, auch hier mit,
so mit, so mit Staff und sowas und so, ja. Das, das, das Dumme ist nur, dass Gale bei mir
diese ultra hässliche Rüstung anhat. Also, Gale sieht bei mir normalerweise, oh.
Ähm, Gale würde normalerweise so aussehen und das sieht ultra hässlich aus, deswegen habe ich ein Mod installiert,
wo man jede Rüstung, die es gibt, in den Camp-Slot packen kann.
Nennt sich,
genau, das ist der Mod hier, da kann man quasi über, da hat er natürlich hier beste, beste Screenshots bekommen, da kann man in den
Unterwäsche-Slot
den Skin ziehen, des Items, wie man aussehen will, so. Das heißt, das da sieht halt richtig dumm aus,
deswegen, so sieht das deutlich besser aus. Das ist der einzige Mod, den ich installiert habe.
Also, einfach, ich habe nur ein Mod installiert, das Gale ordentlich aussieht, weil das ist einfach dumm.
Das sieht so kacke aus, das Ding, ey.
Und so sieht er viel, viel nicer Wizard-mäßig aus. Man kann, also man kann alles reinziehen in den, in den Slot. Ist wirklich dumm.
Aber die Rüstung ist halt extrem nice. Ja, du kriegst Advantage auf Decks, Würfe,
du kannst weiter springen
und
du bekommst bloß zwei Decks. Das ist halt, das ist halt wirklich mega nice. Wie man auch hier sieht, das, der hat, der hat einfach, der hat einfach
19, 19 Armor-Class. Vergleich das mal mit meinem Cleric und meinem Tank, die haben 21.
Also, das ist schon, das ist schon wirklich sehr, sehr pock.
Habe ich, habe ich eigentlich meinen, ich, ich gehe mal rasten kurz.
Muss man, muss man wieder sein. Eine Runde pennen. Du hast genug Lager, ich weiß, ich habe
unendlich viele Lagervorräte.
Außerdem Will, du sollst vorlaufen.
Ich habe nahezu unendlich viele Lagervorräte. Ach ja, und ich habe eine Statue von Kalec im
Lager stehen, so ein bisschen.
Und ich habe eine Statue auch.
Lager stehen, so.
Und was die Statue bringt, ist auch nice. Kalec ist jetzt immer blessed.
Normalerweise ist man ja geneigt, für seinen Main-Character, also in dem Fall bei mir Gale,
so für seinen Main-Character eine Statue zu kaufen. Die kostet 5000 Gold, also ist echt nicht billig.
Aber Kalec kann es halt wirklich gebrauchen.
Perma, Perma-Bless ist halt für einen Nahkampf,
Nahkampf-Melee-Character extrem, wirklich extrem gut. So.
Äh, ich will pennen.
Zack.
Äh, pennen.
Lange Rast. Jawohl.
Let's go.
Oh ne, Story.
Ach so, by the way, nur mal so, das ist Act 3, also wer noch nicht Act 3 gespielt hat
und überhaupt gar nicht gespoilert werden will, wie gesagt, ich mache hauptsächlich Nebenquests, der sollte jetzt nicht gucken.
Okay, Alter, was willst du?
You know what happens now, when it recei-
You feel the Emperor's fear as if it were your own.
Bisschen leise, oder?
Oh, da kommt mir das sowieso vor.
The Elder Brain unleashed will be the end of everything.
Wartet mal, ich bin mir da nicht ganz sicher, ich glaube irgendwas stimmt mit meinem Sound nicht.
Äh, Fenstermodus, jawohl.
Sekunde, ich muss das mal kurz checken, ob Dialog und so laut genug ist.
Alter, das ist immer so eklig, wenn Games den Sound ausmachen, wenn man aus ihnen raus-
Wobei, passt eigentlich.
Oh, die Gesellschaft ist abstoßend.
Genau.
Ne, ist laut genug, passt.
Passt.
Oh, mir ist das-
Oh, das ist mir vollkommen egal, ob der-
Ob der Mind Flayer eine Freundin hat oder nicht, das juckt mich gar nicht.
Ähm.
Grafik, Full-
Yes, aber nicht tausend-
So, perfekt.
Excellent.
Die Vergangenheit ist vorbei, schaut nach vorn.
Perfekt.
Okay, das interessiert mich nicht.
Ich schmutz mir das jetzt an.
Kann ich einfach gehen.
Warum der Rüssel so zuckt, der ist irgendwie ein bisschen verbuggt, ne?
Vielleicht ist er-
Vielleicht ist er erregt, man weiß ja nicht.
Ich will nicht wissen, ob es intimer war.
Ich tendiere zu viel, Alter.
Na komm, wir sind mal nett.
Nein, nein, ich will dich nicht umarmen.
Das war auflustreich.
Okay, nice, wunderbar.
Ich will es gar nicht so sehr im Detail wissen, man.
Eigentlich wollte ich nur in Rupa neben Quiz machen.
Gut, gucken, das Niceste ist, anhand der Statorkada ist jetzt Permablast.
Präge.
Permabräge.
Lager verlassen.
So, jetzt müssen wir unser morgendliches Ritual machen.
Einmal Scratch wieder beschwören.
Einmal Mage-
Mage-Armor.
Einmal
schützendes Bann.
Ich hab das Game schon so lange auf Deutsch, dass ich gar nicht mehr weiß, wie das heißt.
Ich hab das umgestellt, als ich das erste Mal BG3 gestreamt hab.
Und seitdem hab ich es auf Deutsch gelassen.
Manche Sachen sind super weird übersetzt.
Vor allem, wenn die immer was von Gewebe und Netze erzählen und Weave meinen.
Letztens war auch noch sowas.
Ganz komisch irgendwie.
Wurde bei den Antworten oftmals gar nicht weiß.
Okay, sind die Antworten in Wirklichkeit so weird?
Oder passen die kontextmäßig nicht so richtig?
Keine Sorge, ich lese.
Ihr kennt mich lore-technisch.
Ich lese keine Bücher.
Das ist übrigens auch so ein Aspekt, wo ich ganz ehrlich sagen muss.
Da sind die Leute ein bisschen über die Stränge geschlagen.
Und zwar.
Also gut, man weiß ja heutzutage entpört sich jeder über jedes.
Zumindest eine Storyline hier in Akt 3 ist.
Ich zeige euch das mal kurz.
Eine Storyline in Akt 3 ist, dass hier ganz viele ganz komische Sachen passieren.
Akt 3 ist, dass hier ganz viele ganz viele Flüchtlinge sind, die nach Baldur's Gate 3 rein wollen.
Äh, die nicht nach Baldur's Gate 3.
Storyline in Baldur's Gate 3 ist, dass es hier ganz viele Flüchtlinge gibt, die nach Baldur's Gate rein wollen.
Und da sind ein paar Leute auf Reddit übelst ausgeflippt und haben gesagt.
Oh hier, Agenda, Message, Ultra Vogue.
Und jetzt fangen sie damit auch noch an.
Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen.
Ich bin da manchmal auch ein bisschen allergisch dagegen.
Wenn man in so Entertainment Produkten den Leuten wirklich immer voll was auf die Nase binden muss.
Aber in Baldur's Gate 3 finde ich das gar nicht so.
Weil das passt storymäßig ganz gut.
Denn.
Die Flüchtlinge in Baldur's Gate 3.
Die sind tatsächlich ziemlich gut erklärt.
Durch das ähm.
Ja, durch die generelle 5th Edition Dungeons & Dragons Story.
Denn.
Mal mal ein bisschen meine Lore-Kenntnisse flexen.
Und zwar.
Die Flüchtlinge sind nicht irgendwie etwa geflohen, weil sie Bock haben.
Und das einfach nur geil ist für die Story.
Nein.
Die sind aus Elturel geflüchtet.
Oder heißt das Elturel?
Die und die.
Elturel.
Genau.
Und das ist eine Stadt aus einem der letzten Kampagnen.
Die.
Released wurden für.
Also Module.
Wie heißt das offiziell?
Adventures.
Glaube ich.
Die released wurden für 5th Edition.
Also eines der letzten offiziellen großen Kampagnen.
Die released wurden.
Und.
Das nennt sich.
Descends.
Into Avernus.
Und.
Dort ist quasi ganz kurz gesagt.
Stadt.
Ist kaputt gegangen.
Und jetzt irgendwie in der Hölle.
Und ich kann es jetzt gar nicht so im Detail erklären.
Weil das da müsstest du ewig lang ausholen.
Zumindest sind die Leute aus dieser Stadt geflüchtet.
Die man eben in dieser Kampagne eigentlich spielen konnte.
Wenn man es gespielt hat.
Ich finde das mega nice.
Dass die so auch aktuelle.
Dungeons and Dragons Lore Sachen in das Game eingebaut haben.
Ja.
Also mit Spiel meine ich kein PC Game.
Sondern wenn man eben das.
Das.
Roleplay Game an sich spielt.
Ich spiele ab und zu aber nicht offline.
Irgendwie mit Leuten am Tisch oder so.
Sondern online.
Und die sind halt eben aus der Stadt.
Die.
In der Hölle gelandet ist.
Geflüchtet.
Und Baldur's Gate war halt am nächsten.
Ist halt krasser Nerdcon.
Das findet doch jeder geil.
Ja ist echt so.
Also ich mag das dass die hier.
Sie haben wirklich sehr viel eingebaut.
Ein paar Sachen sind nicht so ganz stimmig.
Gerade gut.
Ich will jetzt nicht so sehr.
Aber das Kampfsystem ist halt wirklich weit weg von der Vorlage.
Ich finde es aber auch nicht schlimm.
Ich meine es ist halt ein Game.
Der so ein bisschen die aktuelle.
So die aktuellen 5th Edition Kampagnen kennt.
Und sowas.
Macht das durchaus Sinn dass sie nach Baldur's Gate geflohen sind.
Weil das halt relativ nah dran ist.
Wenn man sich mal anguckt.
Wenn man sich mal eine Karte anguckt.
Dann.
Tja.
Ist auch wurscht.
Und da macht das Sinn weil Baldur's Gate relativ nah dran ist.
Let's go.
Oh.
Das ist immer verdächtig.
Wenn auf einmal vier mal alles fehl schlägt.
Erfolgreich.
Was ist das?
Was? Oh.
Da kann man rein.
Ich würde sagen bevor wir da reingehen.
Bevor wir in den Brunnen reingehen.
War ich hier schon drinnen?
Ja hier war ich schon drin.
Hier habe ich ein bisschen Zeug verkauft.
Gucken wir mal was hier vorne abgeht.
Mit denen.
Mit denen habe ich schon geredet.
Habe ich mit denen hier schon geredet?
Okay nicht wirklich.
Was haben wir hier?
Schwertküstenkuriere.
Ah ich ahne was.
Das sind die denen die Brieftauben fehlen oder?
Ich war nämlich.
Ich bin nämlich letztens random.
Ich habe keinen Guide geguckt.
Ich bin.
Ich bin random hier oben auf den.
Auf das Dach vom Tempel teleportiert.
Und da habe ich Tara gefunden.
Tara ist die Katze von Gale.
Und die hat ein paar Brieftauben verspeist.
Und ich fürchte mal.
Der Typ wird mir jetzt erzählen.
Ihm fehlen ein paar Brieftauben.
Moment Lieferung nicht garantiert.
Moment ich will mal kurz was gucken.
Zack.
Was ist denn hier los?
Alter es ist Sonntag.
Es ist Sonntag.
Lass mich in Ruhe.
Ich sag doch wir müssen jetzt die Brieftauben finden.
Ich muss.
Ich muss kurz auf dem zweiten Bildschirm was gucken.
MonkaW.
Leute soll mich Sonntag mal in Ruhe lassen.
Okay.
Zack.
Okay passt.
Alles gut.
Also was will er denn?
Wisst ihr wo die Vögel verschwunden sind?
Ich könnte die Tauben für euch finden.
Meine Gebühr ist sehr günstig.
Ich kann untersuchen was mit den Tauben geschehen ist.
Okay.
Eins.
Kann man meine Modliste haben?
Meine Modliste.
Ja.
Die ist äußerst gering.
Ich sag doch minimal gemoddet.
Einzig.
Ich habe das da installiert.
Das man.
Also ich habe es hauptsächlich für Gale installiert.
Weil Gale so eine dumme Rüstung bei mir an hat.
Da kann man in den Slot von der Unterwäsche jede beliebliche Rüstung reinziehen.
Und dann mit der Optik rumlaufen.
Das habe ich installiert.
Dann habe ich installiert.
Das da.
Das braucht man dafür damit man das verwenden kann.
Da kann man die Kiste aus dem Tutorial beschwören.
Wo dann die neuen Items drin sind.
Für diesen Transmog Mod.
Und dann habe ich noch BG3 Mod Fixer installiert.
Das braucht man damit die Story funktioniert.
Wurdest du von der Arbeit angeschrieben?
Nein.
Wurde ich nicht.
Genau und damit das Ganze funktioniert.
Habe ich das in den Git.
GitHub BG3 Mod Manager reingehauen.
Ja.
Man braucht den Mod Fixer.
Weil es sonst Probleme geben kann mit der Story.
Wenn man Mods lädt.
Und irgendwie gibt es wohl noch keine offizielle Mod AP.
Die gescheit funktioniert.
Wenn man Mods lädt.
Dann kackt das Game ab beim starten.
Und sagt es kann keine Story erstellen.
Und der Mod Fixer.
Ja.
Fix die Mods.
Indem er quasi ein Fallback macht.
Auf die Story aus dem Save Game.
Und nicht versucht die irgendwie neu anzulegen.
Das war es.
Mehr habe ich nicht.
Also der einzige Mod den ich wirklich installiert habe.
Ist der Transmog.
Ich könnte die Tauben für euch finden.
Meine Gebühr ist sehr günstig.
Ich kann untersuchen was mit den Tauben geschehen ist.
Ja komm wir sind mal selbstlos.
Will ist selbstlos.
Bring alle gefundenen Briefe zu mir zurück.
Na wie gut dass ich die Briefe schon gefunden habe.
Im Vorfeld.
Hier nimm deine Briefe.
Doch habe ich.
Habe ich nicht.
Wait a minute.
Ich habe.
Alter was soll ich denn hier in meinem Inventar finden man.
Oh.
Moment.
Warum es hier keine Drops gibt.
Keine Ahnung.
Weil ich mit Larian nie gesprochen habe.
Ich schreibe einfach nur so.
Ich habe letztens das Scale Inventar aufgeräumt.
Ich glaube ich habe die Briefe verkauft für die Quest.
He lacks critical information.
Ähm.
Wenn ich Glück habe.
Habe ich die Briefe nur hier verkauft.
Five Head Max ja.
Du räumst nie dein Inventar auf.
Und wenn du einmal dein Inventar aufräumst.
Verkaufst du irgendwelche Quest Items.
Perfekt.
Zeigt mir eure Waren.
Oh ich glaube das sind sie.
Anonymer Brief.
Anweisung für eine Spende.
Briefes.
Postmeister Erkundigung nach einer Lieferung.
Hatte ich aber.
Hatte ich aber nochmal Glück.
Nee Carryweight habe ich genug.
Das ist kein Problem.
Ich habe das verkauft.
Weil ich ein bisschen Kohle.
Aber nee.
Ich hoffe das sind die Briefe die er sucht.
Sonst habe ich jetzt echt gelitten.
Und kann die Quest nicht abschließen.
Forschen.
Nein.
Okay ich hoffe das sind die Briefe gewesen.
Ihr müsstet mal meine Traveller Chest sehen im Lager.
Das ist.
Ich habe noch jedes Item von Akt 1.
Ich habe alles noch.
Mein Game hängt für.
Das ist kein Witz.
Ich kann es euch gleich zeigen.
Mein Spiel hängt für eine halbe Minute.
Wenn ich meine Chest leer mache.
So voll ist sie.
Okay.
Hoffentlich sind das die Briefe.
Ist das.
Oh nochmal Glück gehabt.
Quest Doors.
Nein.
Ich hätte da noch nie reingeguckt.
Will ist.
Der nimmt kein Geld.
Der ist übelst heldenhaft drauf.
Gebt mir euer ganzes Gold.
Alles was ihr habt.
Nun.
Hier ist etwas.
Ein Geschenk.
Lass uns das nicht zu jemand anderem erwähnen.
Endlich könnte man.
Das hier auch mal ans Lager senden.
Das hier ans Lager senden.
Das brauche ich da noch.
Und ja im Prinzip diesen ganzen Mist hier.
Den könnte ich eigentlich mal verkaufen.
Auch ans Lager senden.
Jetzt haben wir da genug Platz.
Was ist denn hier.
Und dann.
Und dann gehen wir in den Brunnen.
Hunde Halsband.
Sag bloß das ist das Halsband von Scratch.
Leider haben Pets kein Inventar.
Es gibt ins Lager senden.
Ja das ist die wichtigste Funktion im Game.
Ohne Mist.
Wichtigste Funktion im Game.
Ans Lager senden.
Wie gesagt ich mache eh nur Sidequests.
Aber zu.
So was gibt es hier denn.
Wurf.
Okay die mag ich schon mal nicht.
Ich sage jetzt einfach nochmal Wurf.
Nicht Wurf.
Wurf.
Das dachte ich mir.
Kalag findet sowas witzig.
Okay da können wir sagen Hallo.
Ich möchte einen Hund kaufen.
Ja noch mehr Pets.
Nice.
Ihr wart furchtbar streng mit dem Hund als ich eintraf.
Ähm war sie?
Ich habe die Vorfeld noch gar nicht gesehen.
Es kann sein das am Anfang von Akt 3 was war.
Keine Ahnung.
Sehr sehr nette Zeitgenosse.
Sehr nette Zeitgenosse.
Kann man traden mit denen?
Handeln.
Was gibt es denn?
Nichts.
Milchkanne.
Und ein Gold.
Ohja das lohnt sich richtig zu traden.
Ist das einer eurer Hunde?
Hä?
Was?
Ist das einer eurer Hunde?
Game.
Auf was beziehst du dich?
Meint die Scratch?
Achso.
Oh Scratch.
Das kannst du vergessen.
Chatgy.
Die kriegt nicht Scratch.
Er lebt bei mir.
Ihr könnt ihn nicht einfach mitnehmen.
Moin Hanna CS live.
Ja nein nein nein nein.
Nein nein nein.
Scratch du bleibst bei mir.
Der ist richtig dicke mit Will mittlerweile.
Ja.
Weil Will der einzige in meiner Party ist der mit Tieren reden kann.
Ihr könnt ihn nicht einfach mitnehmen.
No Pass.
Nein kannst du nicht.
Du kannst dich auch verpissen einfach.
Überzeugen.
Okay wo habe ich bessere Aussichten?
Plus 5 plus 4.
Plus 5 plus 4 plus 4.
Okay überzeugen.
Er hat sein ganzes Training vergessen.
Es wäre ein schlechter Einfluss auf eure anderen Hunde.
Okay.
18.
Gut ich habe massig Bonus.
Aber.
Wisst ihr was.
Hä.
Guck mal Bonus 14.
Das sollten wir das sollten wir gut schaffen.
Ich meine da müssen wir schon 2 oder 3 oder so würfeln dass das.
Okay Prager.
Scratch du bleibst.
11.
Das sollte locker passen.
Ja easy.
Easy.
Was für Mods hast du?
Zeige ich dir gleich.
Ich habe 3 Mods aber nur einen der wirklich was macht.
Ich bin nicht überrascht.
Gunwick hat ihn immer gebeten.
Nimm den useless Mutter wenn du so begeistert bist.
Ich habe nichts mehr mit ihm zu tun.
Es geht nicht nur um Scratch.
Sie schmerzt die Hunde immer.
Halt die Klappe.
Letzte Warnung.
Guter Mann.
20.
Okay.
Kriegst du nochmal extra.
Okay wir haben einen Bonus von 11 bis 23.
Also.
Wir sollten wir sollten den Check packen.
Wenn Will jetzt nicht ganz mies wird.
Will.
Come on.
Ah.
Huh.
Bonus OP.
Ich habe schon gedacht wir hätten jetzt direkt Keleton.
Haben wir gerade den maximalen Bonus bekommen.
An Bonus.
Von 3 auf 26.
Oder hat mein Brain gelegt.
Ja.
Zwischab.
Nice.
What.
Scratch.
Alter.
Was ist das.
Hier bleiben.
Was zum.
The fuck.
Warum haut.
Was ist das.
Alter.
Warum ist Scratch weg.
Ist das ein Bug.
Das ist bestimmt ein Bug.
Na geil.
Aber ich kann Scratch wieder beschwören.
Okay ich glaube das ist einfach ein Bug.
Ich hoffe Scratch ist noch da.
Ich gucke mal ob Scratch im Lager ist.
Der stellt sich.
Da ist er noch.
Scratch.
Okay das war nur ein Bug.
Das der abgehauen ist gerade.
Ja.
Ende gut.
Alles gut.
Was Junge.
Gut dass du wieder da bist.
Wo du hingehörst.
Exzellent.
Perfekt.
So mal kurz mit dem reden noch.
Das ist richtig.
Richtig gute Tat vollbracht wieder.
Ups.
Okay.
Ich lasse.
Ich lasse es zu.
Ist okay Will.
Ne.
Dringo.
Gut.
Ach ja.
Chainlaw.
Also den einzigen Mod.
Also ich habe drei Mods.
Aber nur einen der was macht.
Ist der hier.
Guck.
Man kann jetzt.
Seine Rüstung.
Transmoggen.
Zu irgendwas gescheitem.
Weil.
Man kann.
Und die sieht halt.
Seriously.
Mega.
Beschissen aus.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Und der Mod.
Erlaubt es.
Dass man.
Im.
Das ist quasi der.
Der Unterwäsche Slot.
Dass ein Unterwäsche Slot.
Rüstung reinzieht.
Die man dann als Kind.
Drüber verwenden kann.
Man hat immer noch die Stats.
Von der Rüstung.
Ich meine.
Guck mal.
Die Rüstung.
Sieht so dumm aus.
Das habe ich einfach nicht ausgehalten.
Und Helme.
Die Rüstung.
Gehen hat es halt in dem Fall.
Auch nicht.
Aber ich meine.
Who cares.
Ja.
Juckt mich nicht.
Wenigstens.
Sieht geil.
Jetzt halbwegs brauchbar.
Aus.
Und so ein bisschen.
Nach Wizard.
Und nicht.
Irgendwie so.
So.
Necromancer.
Verschnitt.
Der nix auf die Reihe bekommt.
Das ist der einzige Mod.
Den ich.
Den ich dabei habe.
Damit.
Damit man den zum Laufen bekommt.
Muss ich aber noch.
Zwei andere Mods.
Installieren.
Und die Rüstung.
Ist halt richtig gut.
Sie hat einen guten Advantage.
Auf Deckswürfe.
Also auch Fallen entschärfen.
Und Schlösser knacken.
Und so was.
Rennt ein bisschen schneller.
Und das ist wirklich.
Eine richtig gute Caster Rüstung.
Okay.
Dann gehen wir doch jetzt mal.
In den Brunnen.
Und checken mal ab was da so geht.
Habe ich alles beschworen.
Okay.
Will.
Nein.
Für Scratch haue ich jetzt keine Short Rests draus.
So.
Wir haben alles beschworen.
Die hat ihren komischen.
Ihr komischen Vogel am Start.
hat sein Imp am Start. Ich habe Buffs am Start. Gut, dann gehen wir mal in den Brunnen und
gucken was da los ist. Brunnen Eimer? Ach, da kann man wieder hoch. Wie jetzt? Will,
du Kacknoop. Du willst mir ernsthaft erzählen, du kannst da nicht rüber hüpfen oder wie?
Du musst Karlak das halt machen, die kann das auf jeden Fall. Komm her, die springt
hier einmal quer über die Map. Erstmal alle Leichen looten, so wie das sein muss. Was
ist hier hinten? Craftingzeug. Wie jetzt? Also manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, das Game
will mich movementtechnisch gebeten. Ich gehe auf Will, gucke, geht nicht rüber, ich
springe mit einem anderen Charakter rüber, auf einmal kann Will easy rüberspringen.
Mal gucken, ob Will auch easy hier rüberkommt jetzt. Nee, doch. Okay, Game. Ey, musst du es
nicht verstehen. Rucksack, extra Zauber-Slot. Ja, aber Level 1, das juckt ja nur wirklich
gar nicht. Geht es hier hinten irgendwo weiter? Also wenn es hier großartig weiter geht,
geht es noch ein ganzes Stück unten weiter. Dann muss ich mal meine restliche Party nachholen.
Okay, wen haben wir denn? Karlak und Gale konnten rüber. Warum kann Shadowheart nicht rüber
hüpfen? Shadowheart hat keinen Bock. Die ist verbuggt movementtechnisch. Kann auch ohne
Probleme rüber. Ich glaube aber Will hat so ein paar Probleme. Will? Will? Will? Kannst du springen?
Will? Will? Dann muss Will halt rüber teleportieren. Was? Das ist schon doof jetzt. Will ist einfach
nicht agile genug zum rüberspringen. Ja, gut. Kein großartiges Ding. Will kann einfach rüber
teleportieren. Und bestes Item für Will. Man kann einen Spell-Slot restauren für Warlock. Das
hebe ich mir aber auf. Das ist richtig gut für Warlocks. Weil Warlocks haben eh schon so wenig
Spell-Slots und da ist ein Spell-Slot mehr huge. Ein Brief, letzte Warnung. Okay, das heißt nice
lore, gg. Was gibt es denn hier? Gedickt. Heiltränke, Heiltränke kann man immer nicht genug
haben. Aber hier kommt, pass mal auf, hier kommt Will jetzt wieder nicht rüber. Alter Will, du
unagiler Dude, man. Aber kann das sein, dass es hier überhaupt nicht weiter geht? Sehe ich das
richtig? Hier geht es nicht weiter? Game? Ich glaube hier geht es wirklich nicht weiter. Ich teste
mal was. Kann man das, kann man das, kann man das kaputt machen? Ne, hier geht es, hier geht es
schlicht und ergreifend echt nicht weiter. Okay, Karl, komm mal her. Du kannst das, easy. Hier drüben
ist auch einfach gar nichts. Wait a minute. Game, ist das ein Bug? Ich vermute, das ist ein Bug. Also
erstens, dass es noclip hat, der Felsen. Und weiter gehen tut es ja auch nicht, wie man hier sieht. Ich
glaube, wir haben einen Bug in Act 3 mehr gefunden. Na gut, gibt es echt Schlimmeres. Bisschen zu
agile. Scheint so, seht ihr ja mal. Das ist der Beweis, man kann auch zu agil sein. Das war so
ziemlich der sinnloseste Raum bisher in ganz Baldur's Gate 3. Wenn ich Glück habe, kann ich hier
hoch und Will kommt automatisch mit. Ja, hat funktioniert, nice. Weiter geht es. Wo gehen wir
jetzt hin? Hier unten haben wir alles aufgedeckt. Hier ist nichts mehr. In der Scheune war ja auch
nichts großartig. Hier oben geht es nach Baldur's Gate rein. Wir können hier nebenan. Ja, hier unten
haben wir eigentlich alles erkundigt. Sind auch keine Quests mehr am Start. Ich würde sagen, wir
haben alles. Let's go. Lass mal kurz meine Quests gucken. Blablabla, Main Quest juckt mich jetzt
nicht. Ja, Astarion, das machen wir irgendwann mal. Da habe ich jetzt keinen Bock drauf. Ich spiele
mit Astarion nicht. Es sieht so aus, als gäbe es hier nichts mehr. Die nächsten Quests sind hier
oben. Ja, okay, weiter. Gucken wir mal. Gucken wir mal, was hier los ist. Habe ich mit der schon
geredet? Ja. Ich war noch nicht am Tor. Kein Kommentar. Ja.
Ich war noch nicht am Tor. Ich kann da nichts drüber berichten. Ich dachte, Journalisten
sollen neutral sein. Zensur. Klingt, als würdet ihr Gortas Propaganda drucken. Vielleicht schreibt
ihr einfach schlecht. Natürlich nicht. Lass uns mal checken, was hier unten ist. Erst mal hier.
Okay, wir checken jetzt erst mal hier oben ab, was hier oben los ist. Den hatten wir schon. Erst
mal mit allen quatschen. Oh, Autosave. MonkaS. Oh, was ist das für ein? Stahlwächter. Moment,
Will kommt doch aus Baldur's Gate. Ich bin Will Ravengard. Eine Vorstellung ist doch wohl
nicht nötig. Das ist doch gut. So muss das sein. Der kommt doch her. Kommt doch hierher. Hä? Was
hat die gegen mich? Ich habe wichtige Dinge in der Stadt zu erledigen. Ich komme gut 200
Gold. Wen juckt's? Ich bin pleite, aber ich kriege bald Geld. Ich komme. 200 Gold ist ja nichts. Wenn
ich, wenn ich die Chests aus meinem Lager verkaufe, da habe ich irgendwie 5.000 oder so. Ja, schön.
Ich habe doch schon gesagt, ich habe. Okay, da darf ich nicht. Mein Name zählt nicht. Will
Ravengard ist nicht erlaubt. Wozu braucht ihr Datenschutz? DSGVO? Will, warum kannst du nicht
einfach sagen, du heißt Will Ravengard? Ich glaube, die wären aggressive, wenn ich so ein Scheiß
erzähle. Lass mich mal ausprobieren.
I am a Steel Watcher Citizen. Here to serve the people of Baldur's Gate. In the name of Lord
Enver Gortash. State your business. Baldur's Tor ist meine Stadt, meine Heimat. Ja.
Eyes open, body still. Also gut, Augen auf und still halten. Warum?
The Watcher will communicate with our new Intelligence Directorate. They'll determine if
you're a threat to the city. Upstanding citizens have no reason to fear. And you are an upstanding
citizen. Natürlich. Ich fände, Will sieht auch mega seriös aus, schon. Tun, was sie sagt.
Behind the Watcher's gaze a presence awakens. You are seen. You are known.
Woah. My engine, it's almost, I don't know, buzzing. Like it's paying attention.
Your party's prior transgressions are reflected in its stare,
as witnessed by the cult's ever-alert scrying eyes. It has heard the howls of slaughtered
cultists in the deep shadows of Grimforge. And the stone floors left bloodied. It knows
the cold walls of Moonrise Towers. And the cultists who fell there. The Watcher speaks
directly into your mind with a voice like poisoned honey. You are marked for special treatment.
Not simply an enemy of the people, but an enemy of the absolute. Come with or die.
Oh shit! So war das nicht geplant. Ich lass mich aber nicht verhaften. Ich kann doch jetzt
nicht die Stadtwache umbringen. Da kann ich mich da ganz, da kann ich noch nicht mal in die Stadt
rein, ohne dass ich an jeder Ecke irgendwie Leute habe, die mich killen wollen. Okay,
wir können nur darauf hoffen, dass es so ist wie in anderen Gebieten. Wenn ich hier jetzt Leute
kille, interessiert das die fünf Meter weiter nicht mehr. Was? Kalar ist nicht einverstanden?
Warum? Okay, ich kann abhauen nochmal. Das war, okay, das lief nicht so gut. Mich interessiert,
was passiert wäre, wenn ich das andere, wenn ich gesagt hätte, ich gehe wieder. Das interessiert
mich, wie das, wie das jetzt ausgegangen wäre. Und danach versuche ich, versuche ich,
die mal zu beschen. Okay, schon gut, ich mache mich wieder auf den Weg. Mal gucken,
ob sie mich dann lässt. Okay, dann könnte ich einfach gehen. Alles klar, das muss ich jetzt
ausprobieren. Das muss ich jetzt ausprobieren. Ich versuche, die jetzt zu beschen. Mal gucken,
ob das geht. Das Ding sieht halt relativ stark aus und die spielt immer noch auf dem höchsten
Schwierigkeitsgrad. Mal gucken. Aber man muss sagen, der höchste Schwierigkeitsgrad war bisher
jetzt nicht so super, super schwierig. Okay, Stelzmodus aktivieren. Moment, die greifen mich
gar nicht an. Okay, ich will einfach nur mal gucken, was passiert. Kurze Rast. Ich will einfach
nur mal checken, was passiert. Level 5, Level 5 Fireball. Ab in die Zelle! Nein! Okay. Also,
wir müssen, also das ist nicht ehrlich gesagt nicht das, was ich, das will ich nicht spielen.
Ich will mich nicht direkt mit der Stadtwache anlegen. Ich will aber mal checken, lass mich mal
checken, ob ich den Fight gewinnen kann. Okay, nur einen erwischt. Level 5, Spell Recovery. Post
Wayne. Oh, den hat Karnak gerekt, Alter! One Shot! Gehst du weiterhin in der Pause regelmäßig? Ich
gehe nicht nur in der Pause mittlerweile. Ich gehe sogar alle zwei Tage richtig rennen mittlerweile.
Ich bin aktuell bei 6 Minuten 30 pro Kilometer, also ich laufe jeden zweiten Tag 6 Kilometer. Also
ich renne jeden Tag, jeden zweiten Tag 6 Kilometer. Ist das anfällig für irgendwas hier? Resistenzen,
Feuer ist halbiert, Blitzresistenz. Zu gut, dass ich ein AE, ein AE-Eiszauber habe. Orgörris!
Okay, das scheint auch nicht so schwer zu sein, der Fight. Shadowheart, du machst das, was du am
besten kannst. Spirit Guardians. OP AF. Pass auf, die fällt jetzt hin, weil sie da drüber... Ey,
was ist hier los? Bildschlag, jawoll. Ja, haut ruhig auf Karnak drauf. Das ist ja mein Tank. Wenn
ihr die angreift, soll mir recht sein. Au! Au! Orgörris! Auch noch gut Damage gemacht. So,
der, der Rabe, der geht jetzt hier hin und versucht, das Ding zu blinden. Nice,
jetzt trifft es nichts mehr. So, und Karnak killt jetzt einfach die zwei Dudes hier.
Seriously. Vorbei, ja. Okay, Passiv machen wir aus. Hauen wir auf den drauf, 90% Hitrate. Der
sollte den eigentlich killen jetzt. Nice! So mag ich das. Easy Fight. Im höheren Alter,
ja komm, ich bin jetzt 39, ja. Aber du hast schon recht. Also ich würde sagen,
ich bin mit 39 so fit wie noch nie. Oh, shit, da kommen ja noch mehr. Ich sehe schon,
dass das keine allzu gute Idee war, mich mit der Wache hier an dem Tor anzulegen. Aber ich wollte
einfach mal checken. Jawoll. Alter, der Wächter ist auch fast down. Woah, woah, woah, woah, close,
close. So, jetzt ist hier nass. Habe ich irgendeinen Elektroschock-Zauber oder sowas?
Dann kann man nämlich extra, extra Damage machen. Ich würde sagen, wir machen jetzt nichts außer
Damage. Easy. Willst du Spoiler? Nö. Ich bin mir gerade, ich bin mir eh nicht sicher, ob ich das
hier weiterspiele. Ich wollte, ich wollte einfach nur gucken, was passiert, wenn ich die Wache
angreife. Das Game hat mir wirklich 380 mal gesagt, greif nicht die Wache an. Okay,
die ist noch eine Runde hypnotisiert. Der kriegt jetzt eine Runde Level. Magic Missile macht übelst
Damage mit Gale, weil ich Items habe, die quasi raw, raw, ja, Attack, also Zauber-Damage-Würfel
boosten. Passt mal auf, guckt mal. Normalerweise ist Magic Missile so ein, so ein richtiger low,
low, kack low Spell. Selbst abcastet ist es meistens nicht so gut. Aber passt mal auf,
das Ding hat jetzt noch 130 Damage. Passt, ich zeige euch, das ist richtig gut mit den Items
Magic Missile. Ja, guckt mal, das Ding hat noch 130. Ich hoffe, ich hoffe, es hat kein
Force-Resistance dann. Guck mal, das hat einfach 70 Schaden gemacht Magic Missile gerade, 70.
Mit den Items ist es richtig gut. Das Game ist der Meinung, das macht nur, macht nur 35 Damage.
Ja, aber, oh, ich glaube, das explodiert gleich, wenn das so weitergeht. Oh oh, oh oh. Detonation
steht bevor. Oh oh, MonkaS. Ich renne mal lieber weg. Ähm, ähm, ich haue mal ab. Man könnte,
man könnte vielleicht noch, man könnte vielleicht noch ein, okay, ich habe, ich habe Schiss mit
Kalec da drauf zu hauen. Ich muss es mal kurz untersuchen. Detonation steht vor. Dieser Stall
war schon bereit, seine Selbstdetonation vor. Kann ich das, kann ich das einfach killen im
Vorfeld? Okay, wir testen jetzt mal was. Wir testen mal, ob ich das killen kann,
bevor es sich selbst detoniert. Bam, bam. Easy, hat er kaum Damage gemacht. Hätte schon nicht
wegrennen müssen. Ich hätte gedacht, wir deutlich mehr Damage machen. Soll mir recht sein. Nice.
Wir haben es verstanden, dass das Frontpage Material ist. Oh, der ist gehittert. Okay,
das führe ich jetzt wieder raus. Ich meine, wenn wir jetzt cheasen wollen, ja, dann CCen wir die
einfach jetzt nochmal. Machen wir nicht. Wobei, die machen schon gut Damage gerade, die Jungs.
Shit. Ah, shit. Okay, so ist gut. Da kriege ich, da kriege ich die, aber Kalec nicht.
Alle drei hypnotisiert, easy win. Es lebe RNG. Magic Missile. Magic Missile, guck mal,
es macht so krass viel Damage mit den Items. Einfach nur kurz 60 Damage oder 50, 50 Damage.
Ja, ich bin zu nah dran. Oh, Resisted auch noch. Anzeige. Ja, die können nix, oder? Und Will
blastet den jetzt mal schön weg. Bam Bam. Okay, Gale. Ja, Gale. Nur Stadtfachen sind die
ziemlich schwach, ja. Sind ja auch nur Level 8. Äh, hallo? Wrecked. Hardcore Wrecked. Okay,
mal mit Will reden. Will, was sagst du dazu, dass wir gerade Stadtfache, die Stadtfache gekillt
haben? Vielleicht lässt die Führung mit sich reden. Die Führung lässt sicherlich mit sich
reden, nachdem ich gerade die halbe Stadtfache umgebracht habe, ganz bestimmt.
Oh nein. Ich wollte jetzt gar nicht so viel Story mir anhören. Äh, meine,
da steckt noch mehr dahinter. Okay, Gale ist mega schlecht im Überzeugen. Ey, easy. Gale,
perfekt. Will, ich will eigentlich gar nicht mit dir reden. Ich will nur gucken, ob ich neu laden
muss, weil ich die Stadtfache gekillt habe. Okay, perfekt, Will. So, jetzt ist die Frage,
ob ich neu laden muss oder nicht. Erstmal kurz looten. Seriously. Ich darf die nicht mal looten.
Alter, was ist mit euch los? So, ich laufe jetzt mal durch die Stadt und gucke, ob mich instant
die Stadtwache angreift. Okay, was ist mit dir hier los? Greifst du mich an, sobald du mich siehst?
Hallo. Wait a minute. Das interessiert dir überhaupt nicht, dass ich die Stadtwache
umgebracht habe? Okay. Wen soll ich umbringen? Ja, easy, machen wir. Oh, fuck. Ich hole mir das
übelste Disapproval von meinen ganzen Companions ein, Alter. Seit wann ist Khalec dagegen,
dass man irgendwelche Leute köpft? Ich fass es nicht. Hä? Ich habe doch eben gerade gespeichert.
Oh, Game, please. Hä? Ich bin hochgradig verwirrt. Okay, Leute, vergiss, wir lassen das mit der
Stadtwache sein. Ich habe zwischengespeichert, ne? Ich habe keine Ahnung, was da los ist. Wir
lassen das mit der Stadtwache sein. Ich fand das eh eine äußerst... Dopplinglager war dasselbe. Was
meinst du, dass man Leute umbringen konnte, die daneben hat sich interessiert? Ja. Ja,
wir lassen das jetzt. Okay, ich muss noch mal kurz mit Will konversieren.
Excellent, Will. Perfekt. Wir müssen uns jetzt einen anderen Weg reinsuchen. Ganz ehrlich,
der Fight war eine richtig dumme Idee. Ich wollte die Stadtwache eigentlich gar nicht
killen. Also, ich wollte nur gucken, ob der Fight schwer ist. Und eigentlich ist der Fight viel zu
einfach gewesen, für das, dass die da so einen riesen, riesen Viech hatten. Aus Metall. Das
habe ich schon gelootet hier alles. Okay, wo geht's weiter? Rechts rum. Hier war ich schon mal.
Kommt mir bekannt vor. Es kam nur noch ein Speichersymbol. Eventuell Autospeicherung
gewesen. So. Keine Ahnung, wie gesagt, ich wollte die Stadtwache eh nicht umbringen. Das ist wirklich,
wirklich nicht der, nicht der Style. Okay, Kalag, Kalag approved mittlerweile. Also,
Truhe. Ah, hat überall nichts drin. Oh, blicken da unten. Kann man nicht aufhören. Ah, was zum
Schlossknacken? Trap. It's a trap. 15. Ja, easy für Gale. So, 16. Und jetzt Schlossknacken. Wobei,
ganz ehrlich, warum sollte ich das Schlossknacken, wenn Kalag auch einfach, hallo, wenn Kalag auch
draufhauen kann? Also, in Divinity hatten die noch als Mechanic, wie, da ist nichts drin? Doch,
oder? Warum ist da nichts drin? Und nein, sagt mir nicht, dass man mit Kisten kaputt machen,
den Inhalt zerstört. Das ist nämlich nicht so. Keine Ahnung. Da war nichts drin. Hä? Das verstehe
ich nicht. Das interessiert mich jetzt. Also, es gibt, es gab ja mal das Gerücht, dass wenn du
Kisten zerstörst, du den Inhalt zerstörst. Das ist aber eigentlich nicht so. Deswegen bin ich mal
gespannt, was da drin ist. Vielleicht ist es einfach, vielleicht haben jetzt die Entwickler
einfach vergessen. Ist nicht itemisiert. Ja, let's go. Wahrnehmung fehlgeschlagen,
wahrnehm- Och ne, oder? Erfolgreich, ja, nochmal Glück ab. Okay, Bonus hinzufügen. 24, easy für
Gale. Schlossknacken. 15, zack, easy. Deswegen ist die Rüstung so krass, OP. Okay, hä? Also,
wie gesagt, es gibt eigentlich Tests, dass das Zerstören einer Kiste nicht den Inhalt zerstört.
Aber in dem Fall anscheinend ist das anders. So, wo geht's hier lang? Mein Ziel ist ja immer noch,
da unten in die Stadt reinzukommen. Ach, guck mal, hier kann man irgendwo, hier kann man irgendwo
runtertauchen oder so. Gibt's eventuell auch Würfel, ob der Inhalt zerstört wird? Meines
Wissens nach nicht. Hier war ich schon, hier war ich schon, das passt. Ähm, Leute, angeblich ist hier,
geht hier die Quest weiter. Seht ihr hier irgendwas? Ich nicht. Ach, Moment, das ist die
Brücke, unter der ich gerade durchlaufe. Kann das sein? Ich laufe gerade unter der Brücke durch,
wo man oben drüber, oder? Lauf ich gerade unter der Brücke durch, wo ich normalerweise gerade oben
drüber wollte, Freund? Kann natürlich sein. Oh, was ist denn hier? Ein Höhleneingang. Aha, aha,
interessant. Erstmal die Dolchwurzgluten gehöhlen. Wo geht's denn hier lang? Ah,
hier war ich schon mal. Was ist das? Das ist unter dem Kloster. Hier war ich schon mal. Okay,
gut zu wissen. Hm, Trainer. Ist das die, die mir gerade geholfen hat, die Stadtwache loszuwerden?
Ah, gedickt. Der Mansion-Door. Haben wir schon gelernt mit Gale. Aber für Will sind die Spell
Scrolls praktisch, falls man mal, falls man Not am Mann ist. Und Will out of Spell Slots. Okay,
den darf ich nicht looten, weil... Ja, da darf ich den looten. Juckt doch keinen. Ja. Kannst du
da nicht weiter hochlaufen? Wo jetzt? Hier neben? Doch, doch, ich glaub schon. Aber ich
mach erst mal, ich mach erst mal hier unten. Ein Loot-Orgie. Noch mehr zum Buddeln. Das war
das erste Item in dem Game, was ich mir vom Händler gekauft hab. Schaufel. Dass ich das Zeug
ausbuddeln und looten kann. Okay, mehr gibt's hier nicht. Und hier geht's wahrscheinlich auch
nicht weiter, denk ich mal. Gehen wir hier hoch. Checken wir, wo's dann dahin geht. Ah,
hier ist die... Ähm, Leute, ich... Ich kann das... Ich kann noch cheaten, oder? Also,
was heißt cheaten? Ich kann noch, ich kann noch. Passt mal auf, passt mal auf. Wartet mal,
wartet mal. Wait a minute. Das geht bestimmt, das geht bestimmt. Es ist nur die Frage, ob das
Game das mag, dass man das macht. Guck mal, den juckt es überhaupt nicht. Den juckt es halt mal
gar nicht, dass ich in die Stadt teleportiert bin. Ey, was geht, Alter? Das juckt ja nicht.
Ist grad irgendein Typ neben mir immaterialisiert. Pff, wen juckt's? Du bist nur die Stadtwache und
du sollst aufpassen. Ihr wollt den Kopf? Klingt radikal.
Okay, Game verbuggt. So, und jetzt wäre es halt extremely pog
wenn man hier ein Seil oder so runterlassen könnte, aber ich glaube, es gibt zwar Seile,
aber ich glaube, die kann man nicht... Kann man, glaube ich, nicht benutzen. Ja,
ich glaube, das geht nicht. Es wäre zu cool, wenn das geht, aber ich glaube nicht, dass das geht.
Werfen kann man es? Super, das hat's jetzt gebracht. Nee, ich glaube, das geht nicht. Das
ist, glaube ich, zu advance für das Game. Okay, man kann hier rüberspringen. Da kommen die anderen
auch locker hin. Und man kann den Checkpoint einfach easiest umgehen, indem man hier rüberspringt.
Ist das von den Entwicklern wirklich so gedacht, ja? Okay, was haben wir denn hier? Ich würde ja
ganz gerne... Ah nee, hier ist der Höhleneingang. Okay, wir gehen mal in die Höhle abchecken,
was da so geht. Kurze Rast. Eigentlich nicht. Okay, kurze Rast. Was da drin abgeht?
Sind da irgendwelche Kinder rum? Reche die... Leute, ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was ich hier
mache. Was soll ich machen? Wir haben das versteckte Tiefenknobe gefunden. Reche die...
Okay, klar. Ich meine, ich werde bestimmt nicht die Quest ausführen, die Gnome zu killen. Ich
habe die in Akt 1 und 2 gerettet. Dann werde ich die auch in Akt 3 nicht killen. Der Boss erwartet.
Das ist doch schön, dass er hier ist. Guck mal, die sellen auch Zeug. Mal gucken, ob die guten
Kram haben. Habt ihr was zum Handeln? Was haben wir denn hier? Blitzblender? Ach,
irgendwelche... Wow, das ist aber ganz schön teuer. Und ich benutze ja normalerweise das Zeug
gar nicht. Ich habe noch tausend so Werfwaffen in der Truhe. Deine waffenlosen Angriffe mache ich
nicht. Flink Gnome erhalten und bin ich nicht. Über Anstrengung im Kampf. Überschreite deine
körperlichen Grenzerleiter 6 bis, um einen zusätzlichen Angriff pro Zug durchzuführen und
eine Bewegungsrate zu verdoppeln. Ich weiß nicht, ob es das wert ist. Es hat einen Kaleck für
Handschuhe. Für die wäre das höchstens was. Deine Waffenangriffe bewirken 1 bis 4 Feuerschaden.
Das ist ja ein übelst mieser Handschuh, den ich mit Kaleck anhabe. Da soll ich mal auch bei mir
in der Lagerkiste gucken. Einmal pro kurze Rast. Also 6 bis 36. Das ist irgendwie 20 im Durchschnitt.
Das kann echt ganz gut sein, wenn man es gerade mal braucht, einen zusätzlichen Angriff durchzuführen.
Das ist gar nicht so übel. Ich meine, ich habe genug Kohle. Kaufe das mal.
Ist gar nicht so schlecht, extra Angriff. Mit wem habe ich das jetzt gekauft? Das Game ist ultra
PP in dem, was es anzeigt. Seht ihr das? Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn. Hä? Hä? Was? Game. Guckt mal.
Ey, Alter, was? Jetzt sind wir doch bei plus 12. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das Game da macht,
wenn man Items wechselt. Okay, ich blicke es nicht. 15, jetzt haben wir angeblich insgesamt 14. Und
damit haben wir insgesamt 12. Okay, nice. Passt doch. Und warum habe ich damit jetzt weniger,
obwohl die Sachen damit überhaupt nichts machen? Keine Ahnung. Also irgendwie, an manchen Stellen
ist das Game echt eine Runde highly PP-iger. Wo haben wir denn extra Angriff denn jetzt? Hier.
Kann ich das irgendwie so hinlegen, dass ich es sehe? Okay, range attack mache ich eh so gut wie nie.
Ganz gut. Übrigens, Karlag hat einen mega geilen Speer. Guckt mal. Den kann man werfen und dann
ist er automatisch wieder da und kann ihn wieder werfen. Das ist extremly POG. Ich sollte den mehr
werfen. Okay, was haben wir denn sonst noch hier? Okay, mit der darf ich nicht reden. Darf ich mit
der reden? Ach, die ist das! Das ist die, die ich davon abgehalten habe, sich in die Luft zu
sprengen in Akt 1. Hat sich schon mal gelohnt. Erstmal alles looten. Ordentlich weggelootet.
Trainer, Lehrling und Wulbrin! Da ist er! Der Wulbrin.
Jetzt weiß ich es wieder.
Natürlich. Will ist der Widerstandskämpfer in Person. Jetzt weiß ich es wieder. Das ist den,
den ich aus dem Gefängnis gerettet habe Ende Akt 2. Wo das Game wollte, dass man das super
sophisticated macht mit werfe mir einen Hammer durch die durch die Gittertür und ich bin einfach
hingegangen, habe den Aufseher gekillt und habe sie rausgelassen. Ich halte zu, ich gotte mich so
gut wie tot. Ich habe meine eigenen Gründe, ihn zu töten. Das ist ehrkraftlich meiner.
Schalte die Stahlwache aus.
Na dann war das vielleicht doch vorhin gut, dass ich den Fight angefangen habe mit denen.
Reg dich ab. Reg dich ab. Kopf hoch Wulbrin.
Ah ok. Oh eine Baldurs 1 Referenz. Das ist der Boss von Baldurs Gate 1 gewesen.
Ok Wulbrin ist gut. Hast du was zum traden Wulbrin? Irgendwas? Was hast du?
Wulbrins Hammer und Silber. Ok es hält sich doch hart in Grenzen.
Was ist euer Plan?
Ok auf geht's.
Ich bin mir da ehrlich gesagt nicht so sicher, ob ich irgendwelche Bomben in die Stadt bringen soll.
Das ist keine so gute Idee Wulbrin. Kann ich nicht sagen, ich überlege es mir nochmal.
So das ist jetzt wieder sowas, wo ich nicht weiß, wie das Game sich verhält. Ich würde gerne das
da sagen, aber man weiß ja nie, was dann passiert.
Dann sprenge ich die Gieße rein. Ne ne ne. Shadowheart ist nicht, es juckt mich nicht.
Will ist inspiriert, bloß die Hände nicht schmutzig machen.
Inspiration. So und was mit den anderen Leuten? Hier war doch eben noch mehr
Leute mit denen ich reden konnte oder? Sind die jetzt weg?
GG super nützlich.
Das ist die, die mir oben geholfen hat mit dem komischen Viech da.
Klingt ziemlich gefährlich.
Ja ansonsten können die mal schön machen, was sie wollen würde ich sagen.
Okay, ist ja was ich ich nehme ich nehme die Rundenpulver Bombe von Wulbrin mal mit.
Wie viel wiegt denn das Ding? 16 Okay, wo bist du?
Aufheben.
Okay, das Game hat ein paar Probleme damit, wenn man das jetzt aufgehoben hat,
sieht so aus.
Hier, wo kommt man? Wo kommt man hier raus?
Ebel.
Wo kommen wir jetzt raus?
Ach hier sind vier. Da habe ich mich das letzte Mal schon gefragt.
Wie kommt man denn hier rein?
Bei der Schmiede sind vier. Okay, so jetzt haben wir glaube ich alles.
Nee, linke Seite waren wir noch nicht.
Da gehen wir jetzt nochmal hin, wir gehen jetzt die linke Seite nochmal abchecken.
Zwar nicht hier lang, sondern da lang.
Da unten hin.
Hier hin.
Da wollen wir hin.
Und dann springen wir über die Seite in die Stadt rein.
Weil dann müssen wir die auch nicht killen.
Weißt du was ich richtig nice finden würde?
Wenn man irgendeine Option hätte für Zeitvorspulen oder schneller rennen.
In BG1, 2 und Icewind Dale und so, da konnte man einfach haste casten und ist dann
mega schnell über die Map geflitzt.
Aber das geht hier nicht.
Man kann zwar haste casten, aber ich glaube mit haste läuft man auch außerhalb vom Kampf nicht schneller.
Außerdem ist nur ein Charakter.
Trap!
Tasche mit essen.
Kann man nicht anklicken, okay.
Dann muss Gail mal wieder ran, entschärfen.
Gail ist mein Entschärfungsmeister, seitdem er die Decksrüstung an hat.
18 ist natürlich hart.
Ja, nice.
Sehr schön.
Okay, eine Inspiration setze ich dafür drauf, weil Gail ist eh immer max inspirated bei mir.
Okay, das sollten wir haben.
Lauf halt drum herum.
Das Problem ist, dass es meine Companions nicht so sehen.
Die rennen immer rein.
Guck hier, die rennen da garantiert rein.
Ich meine, wir können mal was anderes probieren.
Und zwar, wartet mal, wir könnten, wir können mal probieren, ob wir.
Ich wollte sagen, wir können mal probieren, wenn wir von weitem drauf schießen, ob es dann, ob es dann vielleicht kaputt geht.
So war das nicht gedacht.
Was ist hier vorne los?
Was geht hier?
So, und jetzt erst mal, erst mal handeln, gucken, was er hat, beste, beste Taktik.
Sondern jetzt passt mal auf, wisst ihr, was halt immer ein bisschen, bisschen weird champig in RPGs ist?
Und zwar, ich kann jetzt, ich kann, ach, ich will doch nicht handeln.
Ich kann jetzt Charakter wechseln, irgendwo.
Äh, Charakterauswahl, ich gehe zu Shadowheart, guck, der Typ hat eins von 31 schwer verwundet.
Guck, diese Person kann nicht geheilt oder gerettet werden.
Das ist halt auch so ein Ding.
Das müssen die einbauen, dass halt Quests funktionieren, weil ansonsten, ich hätte jetzt gesagt, ich gehe einfach hin und heile den Typ, aber das geht natürlich nicht.
Und ich wette mit euch, dass selbst, das wird nicht funktionieren.
Ich will, ich will aber mal gucken, wie, wie weit sie gedacht haben.
Wir können den besten Spell nehmen, um solche Sachen zu beheben.
Wir können nämlich einfach sagen, vollständige Genesung, vollständige Genesung.
Siehste, bringt gar nichts.
Das dachte ich mir.
Aber das musst du in Games halt so machen, sonst kannst du keine Quests.
Überlegt euch mal, wenn du, wenn du einfach bei jedem Quest jeden NPC wiederbeleben könntest, heilen könntest, dann könntest du keine gescheiten Quests mehr machen.
Okay, Will, auf geht's.
Wer führt euch an, was ist passiert?
Versuchen, ihm zu helfen.
Oh.
Weggehen, Bass.
Wow, oh, Alter, was geht mit dir ab?
Keine Panik, ganz ruhig.
Okay, alles, überladen.
Okay, was gibt's hier?
Frischer Leichnam.
Money, Bässe.
Oh.
Hier, Dampfer, hier ist Gas.
Das explodiert.
Pass mal auf.
Larian Studios Logic.
Hä, hä, hä, hä.
Okay, sehr schön.
Aber das Fisch kann ich nicht killen.
So, und ich hoffe, die Falle löst jetzt nicht aus, wenn ich unten langlaufe.
Horst Champ.
Brücke, wo führt das hin?
Bestimmt, das bestimmt sind unsere Brücke.
Okay.
Aber er kommt bestimmt in so eine Seitenroute nach Baldur's Gate rein.
Hier geht es sonst nicht weiter.
ASMR, Nature Sounds.
Was passiert?
Oh, automatisches speichern.
Was passiert, wenn ich hier runter springe?
Geht nicht.
Oh, man kann es ja aber ausprobieren.
Stimmt, das ist das Schiff.
Ja, ich erinner mich.
Das ist das Schiff, wo man gesehen hat, wie das aus Moonrise Towers abfährt.
Ich mach' ein guter Exp bei Level 11.
Schade, dass bei Level 12 das Spiel zu Ende ist.
Wobei, nicht zwangsläufig das Spiel, aber XP-Cap.
Was ist hier los?
Du, hilf mir, diese Arschlöcher zu töten.
Die Gilde wird dich mit Gold verspringen.
Kann ich nicht erstmal fragen, Jungs, was geht hier eigentlich ab?
Wäre das nicht die logische Variante, anstatt zu sagen, ich bring' dich oder dich um,
zu fragen, was ist denn hier eigentlich los?
Nur so, Will, nur so eine Idee, ja?
Können wir uns nicht vertragen, müssen wir wirklich kämpfen?
Die Antwort ist so blöd, die muss ich jetzt nehmen.
Ha!
Was?
Yep, hat er gerade das Wort gesagt.
Yep, Klok.
Ne, die dürften sich ruhig gegenseitig bashen, soll mir recht sein.
Ne, ne, passt schon, haut euch mal gegenseitig kaputt, alles gut.
Ich glaube, das war die dümmste Antwort von allen, die ich nehmen konnte.
Weil jetzt sind sie beide feindselig und ich kann mit keinem von denen reden.
Das war äußerst pippiger.
Aber, was willst du machen?
Feuerwand, oh, Feuerwand ist exzellent hier jetzt.
Oh, beste Leute!
Jetzt fackeln sie alle ab!
So mag ich das.
Kahlkeule.
Zu hocharm ist, ich dachte...
Immer, immer noch zu hoch, Arsch.
Ja, man könnte mit Will vielleicht irgendwie hier oben drauf hüpfen oder so.
Guck mal, die bleiben, die bleiben lieber im Feuer stehen, anstatt da rauszulaufen.
Nein, Shadowheart, ich will nicht eingreifen.
Okay, und jetzt, und jetzt, pass mal auf, und jetzt setzen wir noch eins drauf.
Ähm...
Ne, komm, wir machen keinen Eissturm.
Jetzt setzen wir noch eins drauf und weißt du was?
Komm!
Level 4 Fireball.
Wreckt.
Komplett wreckt, Alter.
Ah, okay, die leben noch.
Eigentlich sogar ganz gut.
Ähm...
Zeichen des Jägers auf Will.
Ne.
Dafür euch keinen Spellslot raus.
Ich hab mich einfach nicht treffen lassen von dem.
Äh, ihr habt kein Damage gemacht.
Äh, was? Dornenhagel, okay.
Das Counterspellen war mal.
Die Feuerwand war richtig nice.
Die, die konnten ja gar nichts machen, die sind einfach alle verreckt.
Okay, Scratch, du bleibst.
Scratch, bleib einfach mal hier hinten stehen.
Shadowheart!
Kannst du da hinrennen? Ja, perfekt.
Level 3, sparen wir mal ein bisschen Spellslots, dass wir nicht gleich wieder rasten müssen.
Level 3 Spirit Guardians, und jetzt?
Einfach Damage machen.
Ja, komm, ein Spellslot für euch, da hinten hauen wir noch raus.
Hat jemand von euch Divinity Original Sin 1 und 2, oder 2 alleine, auf Tactician-Mode gespielt?
Ich, also ich hab es nicht auf Tactician durchgespielt.
Aber ich hab gehört, dass Tactician in, äh, Divi, in Original Sin 2 richtig schwer, äh, schwer gewesen ist.
Ich hab gehört, dass Tactician in, äh, Divi, in Original Sin 2 richtig schwer, äh, schwer gewesen sein soll.
Magische Geschosse auf sechs Ziele.
Nicht reagieren.
Okay, Karek, du darfst die hier bashen jetzt.
Den Typ da darfst du bashen.
Ja.
Hm.
Okay, Karek, wir probieren mal was.
Mal gut, wie, mal gut gucken, wie gut deine Wurfangriffe sind.
Ziemlich gut, würde ich sagen.
Ziemlich nice!
Jetzt kannst du da hinrennen.
Äh.
Leute, ich, warum hat Karek auf einmal so viel, so viel Movement Speed?
Eben hatte die noch, eben konnte die gar nicht so weit laufen.
Hä?
Also manchmal ist das Game weird.
Und vorbei.
High Speed Sprinting.
So, Will ist dran.
Will wird die jetzt wegblasten.
Und wahrscheinlich stirbt die dabei auch.
Oh, drei!
Aber bei der nächsten, spätestens wenn die in die Spirit Guardians rennt, ist sie dead.
Es wäre ja cool, wenn...
Hoffentlich hat er kein Shield.
Ah, okay.
Ey, da komm ich nicht dran.
Komm ich leider nicht dran.
Okay, den killen wir.
Und die killen wir.
Und...
Ja, hier machen wir Damage drauf.
Oh, ne!
Lass Gale in Ruhe!
Ey!
Oh!
Jetzt willst du das, jetzt willst du das Viecher aber wissen.
Ja, pff.
Wisst ihr was?
Sollen die sich mal ein bisschen kloppen?
Ich, ich heile.
Ich heile mal kurz ne Runde.
Ja, perfekt.
Wobei, eigentlich... Ja doch, komm!
Ach so!
Ne, das ist ja ein unsinniger Healspell in dem Fall.
Eigentlich muss ich nicht heilen.
Wir machen das hier mal, das ist gut.
Das geht bis zur nächsten langen Rast, das ist ziemlich nice.
Dann kriege ich 15, 15 Extratrefferpunkte oder so.
Ganz praktisch.
Oh, komm.
Lass dich aber noch selbst heilen.
Äh, magisch geschossen.
Ach, komm!
Counterspell, wurscht.
Wir können eh short resten und dann hat Will wieder alle...
...Zauber am Start.
Okay, Karl, auf geht's!
Will, es steht niemand mehr im Feuer drinne.
Deswegen würde ich sagen...
Will, Will, wo bist du?
Will, Will.
Will?
Verbugged.
Will, mach mal deine Feuerwand aus.
Das Karl, da durch...
Ist 99 Trefferpunkte Cap oder ist das einfach Zufall, dass ich 99 Trefferpunkte hab?
Poor fucker.
Ich hab 99 Hitchans, man.
Zufall, okay.
Ja, eigentlich kann's nicht Cap sein.
Das war's jetzt, oder?
Ah, nee, einer ist noch da.
Okay, Will, jetzt blaste den mal weg.
Der hat ge...
Doch, doch nicht...
Drei!
Okay.
Ge...
Okay, Gail.
Du hast jetzt die Chance, den zu killen, bevor er dich killt.
Du musst einfach nur hitten.
So, einfach mal...
...Mörderhobo einfach mal alles umgebracht, was da war.
Aber was kann ich dafür?
Letter.
Okay, erstmal alles weglooten.
Looten.
Was ist hier?
Leichenschleifer, ein...
Ist das ein Kriegshammer?
Zweihandhammer.
Hatte ich, glaube ich, noch nie in dem Game.
Waffenverzauberung plus zwei.
Okay, nee, das ist...
Das ist Schrott für mich.
Hat...
Hat Shadowheart zufälligerweise Proficiency mit Zweihandhämmern?
Meine passt nicht so wirklich zu der.
Nee, hat sie nicht.
Hat sie nicht.
Will ist ein bisschen...
...ein bisschen voll.
Krieg Gale.
Jetzt haben wir wieder Platz.
Oh, guck mal.
Ein...
...ein weiteres...
Ich benutze es ja so gut wie gar nicht, diese Mindflayer-Fertigkeiten.
Da geht's rein.
Gullywook.
Lasst uns erst mal abchecken, was auf dem Schiff ist.
Ich glaube, wir haben alles gelootet jetzt.
Moment, Shadowheart, du hast doch eigentlich normalerweise auch ein Pet.
Wo ist denn dein Pet?
Ja.
Was haben wir denn Schönes auf dem Schiff?
Eine steinerte Muschel.
Okay, einfach mal random shit aufgehoben.
Ach, das ist ein Schild!
Okay, das dürfte das most useless Schild ever sein.
Ich will mal aber kurz gucken, wie das aussieht.
Okay, das sieht auch noch irgendwie dumm aus.
Na, CU-Schild.
Meergras.
Gehen wir mal aufs Schiff gucken.
Das hat noch dieses Zeug aus Act 2 dran, das Schiff.
Granate.
Ach, guck mal!
Elf Stück schon!
Jetzt könnte ich eigentlich komplett auskillen.
Alles, was es gibt mit elf.
Nichts für mich.
Kann man hier irgendwie unter Deck?
Nee.
Nee, nee.
Ist ja hier zugestellt.
Normalerweise müsste es ja hier runter gehen.
No Pass.
Hier geht es nicht weiter.
Dann bleibt ja im Endeffekt nur hier hinten der Gang.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Ja, hier ist nichts mehr.
Hier geht es auch nicht weiter.
Ja.
Bleibt ja eigentlich nur hier hinten.
Gehen wir mal hier rein checken.
Abchecken, was da ist.
Wo sind wir denn?
Ich dachte, man sieht vielleicht den Namen von der Map.
Oh nein!
Es ist Will besoffen.
Er isst eine harte Wurst, genau.
Wie lange ist Will noch besoffen?
Nee, er ist nicht mehr besoffen.
Oh, da unten geht es aber ganz schön weit rein.
Oh, das ist auch Teil der Map.
Okay, gut, gut, gut.
Was hier?
Ähm.
Was ist eine Poutine?
Poutine?
Ähm, sind das, sind das...
Pommes frites?
Irgendwie so Pommes frites mit Käse oder so?
Was ist das?
Sieht auf jeden Fall so aus, als könnte man sich das mal gönnen.
Pommes frites?
Fast Food.
Okay, es ist Pommes frites mit Käse drüber und Bratensauce.
Boah, das ist ja eine heftige Mischung, Alter.
Pommes frites mit Käse und Bratensauce.
Schmecken tut es aber wahrscheinlich...
Ja, bestimmt, ja.
Alles Fettige und Kalorienhaltige schmeckt meistens.
Erstmal alle Bilder, erstmal alle Bilder klauen.
Ja, Kunst, Kunstraub.
Beste Mischung.
Oh!
Trap?
Oh, Schatzkisten.
Oh guh, was haben wir denn hier Schönes?
Geil, entschärfe mal.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Knochendornstiefel.
Solange du weder Rüstung noch Schild trägst.
Das ist was für Will?
Will trägt keine Rüstung, er trägt nur Staub.
Springe ein Ziel an, stoße es möglicherweise um,
sodass es liegend ist.
Okay, das ist eher so eine Barbarian-Geschichte.
Aber Will wird das anziehen jetzt.
Weil Will hat bei mir...
Die Schuhe, die Will hat, sind auch aus Akt 1.
Und zack, ein Total.
Weiß nicht, warum ich die nie umgezogen hab.
Mit welchem... mit... Leute mit... ja.
Dann zieht Will das jetzt nämlich an und kriegt einfach ein AC mehr.
Will, warum kriegst du nicht AC?
Du hast keine Rüstung an, du hast Stoffrobe an.
Das zählt normalerweise nicht als Rüstung.
Solange du weder Rüstung noch Schild trägst.
Ja?
Will?
Gutschy Bus?
Hä?
Game, was ist denn das hier wieder?
Zählt das hier als leichte Rüstung?
Ach, das zählt als...
Oh, come on, Game, please.
Die ist aber sehr praktisch.
Diese Mütze, da kann sich Will nämlich unsichtbar machen.
Das ist sehr praktisch, wenn Will auf den Sack kriegt.
Okay.
Will, dann zieh halt deine random Stiefel an, die du die ganze Zeit hast.
Das ist auch komplett unsinnig und bringt dir nix.
Schatzkisten.
Ja, klar.
Obviously, das, was ich genommen hab,
diese zwei Steine und das bisschen Gold,
war natürlich in Wirklichkeit fünf Kisten voll.
Natürlich, Game.
Dann gucken wir doch mal, was hier unten ist.
Ach, hier kann man runterklettern.
Wir müssen hier ein bisschen...
ein bisschen aufpassen, dass wir...
Ach nee, gibt's hier nicht.
Ich hab gedacht, hier kommt vielleicht irgendein Boss oder sowas.
Nee.
Walnuss, Melone.
Gewehr.
Vorräte looten.
Noch ein Ball, da freut sich Kratzer.
Seidenwurzel.
Ich hab...
Ich hab grad was anderes gelesen.
Nicht weitersagen.
Oh, Top Secret.
Aha.
Geheime Sachen.
Exzellent.
Aber Bötchen fahren kann man auch nicht.
Okay, komm.
Loot mal alles.
Okay, das war's. Mehr gibt's hier nicht.
Map.
Ich würd sagen, wir haben auch alles soweit aufgedeckt.
Dann gehen wir mal wieder.
Jetzt müssen wir schauen, wie wir nach Ballos Gate reinkommen.
Ach, hier gibt's was.
Nicht gesehen.
Nachrichten für...
Metalskette.
Ohrring.
Wird alles gekrappt.
Alles weggelootet.
Soll ich mal sagen, ich find das gar nicht schlecht gemacht hier.
Es gibt ja so aktuell die Kritik, dass Akt 3 noch ein bisschen Probleme mit Storyenden, Content und Bugs hat.
Ja, Bugs hab ich jetzt auch.
Aber wisst ihr, eine Sache, die ich schon fast...
fast zu übertrieben fand in Akt 1 ist,
in Akt 1 hattest du wirklich jeden Meter, den du über die Map gelaufen bist, war irgendetwas.
Das war zu dense, um realistisch zu wirken.
Oder um immersive zu wirken.
Versteht ihr, wie ich mein?
In Akt 1 bist du gelaufen, bam, da was.
Bist du gelaufen, da war was.
Da was. Da steht ein NPC.
Da liegt irgendwas.
Ah, okay, hier ist noch was.
Ah, hier ist was zum Ausgraben.
Du konntest keine zwei Meter in Akt 1 laufen, ohne dass was war.
Ja, so cool das war, weil's viel zu entdecken gab,
war die Content-Dichte in Akt 1 halt auch viel zu krass eigentlich, wenn man sich's mal überlegt.
Das wirkte einfach so zugeflastert.
Wie kommt man jetzt hier raus?
Okay, ich dachte eigentlich, man kann das hier irgendwie umlaufen.
Geht's denn hier lang?
Es ist auch unglaublich viel nicht ins Spiel gekommen.
Ja, Larian hat ja gesagt, sie wollen weiter dran arbeiten, was ich sehr nice finde.
Wait, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp.
Ach nee, hier ist ja gar nix, ne?
Was ich sehr nice finde, und ich gehe stark davon aus, die machen so eine Art...
...Definitive Edition.
Wo dann nochmal alles reinkommt, das wär schon richtig nice.
Dann spiel ich das auch nochmal durch.
Es ist zwar für mich, also für jemand, der BG 1 und 2 auch hunderte Stunden gesuchtet hat,
kein wirkliches Baldur's Gate 3 im Sinne von 1 und 2,
aber ist trotzdem nach wie vor ein mega nices Game.
Was? Das hab ich gar nicht gesehen.
Guck mal hier, wie kommt man da hin?
Okay.
So, wir haben jetzt immer noch das Problem, wie kommt man nach Baldur's Gate rein?
Also, mein Game ist lustigerweise der Meinung, hier geht's weiter, was aber...
...debated, overrated, outdated ist, was offensichtlich nicht stimmt.
Ich weiß, was wir machen. Wir gehen hier hin und springen und springen auf der anderen Seite rüber.
Mit dem, es ist so vieles nicht ins Hauptspiel gekommen, woher weißt du das?
Haben die sich da mal in irgendeinem Interview geäußert?
Oder, oder, oder...
Oder hast du's ausgedacht?
Ey, wahrscheinlich hast du's nicht ausgedacht, aber...
Also, woher weißt du das? Ich hab die Interviews nicht so verfolgt.
Ich mein, man kann sich's denken, weil ja auch einiges unfertig ist, bzw. wo man denkt, ja, da kam garantiert noch mehr, aber...
...aber haben die irgendwas dazu gesagt?
Ist in jedem Game so.
Ja, es ist ein Unterschied, ob im Vorfeld absichtlich was rausgenommen wurde...
...wo man irgendwann dran angefangen wurde zu entwickeln...
...oder ob es so war, man musste es rausnehmen ein paar Wochen vor Release, einfach weil man nicht fertig geworden ist.
Stand auf Reddit? Ja.
Na, Reddit, dann stimmt das auch.
Das hinterfrage ich nicht, wenn's auf Reddit steht.
Auf Reddit ist alles immer true.
Ich hab's noch nie erlebt, dass auf Reddit einer was geschrieben hat, was nicht stimmt.
Sind wir uns einig, Reddit ist immer...
...die Wahrheit.
Aber es kann durchaus sein, also es...
...es passt ja irgendwie auch.
Gerade, gerade was Act 3 angeht, also ich hoffe echt...
...ich mein, die haben hoffentlich massig Geld gemacht mit dem Game...
...und die haben ja auch Original Sin noch ordentlich dabei gepatcht, also...
...es wäre auf jeden Fall cool, das Game...
...ganz ehrlich, in der Qualität hätte das Game durchaus sogar einen vierten Akt verdient.
Wobei ich das halt von der Story her nicht sagen kann...
...weil ich den Ausgang der Story noch nicht kenne.
Aber, aber, also...
...ich glaube, sie können...
...zumal sie sich ja die Lizenz gekauft haben, Baldur's Gate...
...Sachen erstellen zu dürfen.
Übrigens, das war so, das hab ich in einem Interview gelesen...
...es geht ja so das Gerücht um, so nach dem Motto...
...Larian hatte halt total viel Geld...
...weil Wizards of the Coast mit dabei war...
...Moment.
Jetzt bring ich's durcheinander.
Wizards of the Coast, sind das die Warhammer?
Ne, ne.
Wizards of the Coast sind die D&D-Leute und...
...Dingsbums Games Workshop sind die Warhammer-Leute.
Bring ich immer durcheinander.
Weil die denen ganz viel Geld gegeben haben, das stimmt überhaupt gar nicht.
Larian hat sich die Lizenz von denen gekauft, um Baldur's Gate machen zu dürfen...
...die haben dafür bezahlt.
Und darf ich euch nochmal was an was erinnern?
Wisst ihr noch, für welche Plattform...
...Baldur's Gate 3 als erstes angekündigt wurde?
In welchem Stream?
Wer weiß es noch?
Hat noch irgendjemand eine Ahnung, was das war?
Ich such grad das Emote dafür, ich find es nicht.
Es war nämlich eine Plattform...
...über die redet heute keiner mehr.
Baldur's Gate 3 wurde zuerst angekündigt...
...für...
...Stadia!
Falls sich da noch irgendjemand dran erinnern kann.
Guck mal!
Die Plattform gibt es schon nicht mehr, jetzt wo das Game rausgekommen ist.
Okay, ich bin begeistert, dass der Kontrollpunkt so wahnsinnig effektiv ist.
Was haben wir denn hier schönes? Eine Holztruhe.
Oh, ey!
Ne, ich hab...
Was denn? Ich hab doch gar nichts gemacht.
Benehmt euch bitte, ja!
Ich verschwinde hier, ist gut.
Ist gut.
Aber was viel besser ist...
Will, Will, Will, rede mal mit dem Typ.
Rede mal mit dem Typ.
Und ja, handel mal mit dem Typ noch viel besser.
Und dann switchen wir den Charakter.
Und Gail...
Du lootest jetzt einfach mal...
...hart hier alles weg.
Wobei, hier ist ja nichts, was mich interessiert.
Hauptsache den Eintrank gelootet.
Okay, ich hab gesagt, ich verschwinde hier.
Mal checken, was passiert, wenn ich hier weiterlaufe.
Ob die mich dann attacken.
Elixier der Hügelriesenstärke.
Oh, das ist was Nices.
Das kann man bestimmt gebrauchen.
Was haben wir denn hier oben?
Was?
Ich hab überhaupt nichts geklaut, Alter!
Was willst du nur von mir?
Was willst du?
Wer würde so etwas nur tun?
Ja, frage ich mich auch, ich nicht.
Kommt da einfach angerannt und sagt, ich hätte was geklaut.
Oh!
Äh...
Äh, ich glaube, mein Spiel ist gerade ein wenig...
...am abkacken.
Game?
Was, was zum Teufel geht hier gerade ab?
Muss, muss ich den...
Muss ich den Dude jetzt wirklich umbringen, weil er mich beim Klauen erwischt hat?
Okay, ich blaste den jetzt mit Will vom Turm.
Passt auf.
Oh nein!
Shit!
Ich hätte doch nichts klauen sollen, Alter.
Und ich hätte nicht vom Turm werfen sollen.
Der konnte mich überhaupt nicht erwischen beim Klauen.
Ich war schon längst weg.
Die Diebesbeute übergeben.
Ja, hier hast du es wieder.
Okay, kein Starten entstanden.
Easy, kein Problem.
So muss, so, so wäre gut, wenn es in echt auch geht.
Probier mal was zu klauen und wenn sie dich erwischen, sagst du, ach sorry.
Hier hast du es wieder.
Ich geh dann mal.
Ist das Max First Place?
Ja.
Ist es.
Okay, kann ich das hier jetzt klauen, ohne dass der das sieht?
Alter!
Was ist mit dem Dude los?
Warum hat der mitbekommen, dass ich hier oben was geklaut habe gerade?
Der ist ja super sus.
Und jetzt ist das Game verbuggt.
Jetzt komme ich nicht mal die Leiter runter.
Geil!
Top!
Ganz toll!
Yeah!
Okay, wir probieren jetzt mal was.
Warte mal.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob das was bringt, aber...
Warte mal, ich will nur mal gucken, ob das geht.
Okay.
Wisst ihr was?
Wir machen was anderes.
Kalec?
Kalec, komm mal her.
Komm mal her.
Oh shit!
Warum aggro'n die immer da unten?
Das ist doch kacke.
Ich will nicht, dass die aggro'n.
Ich will keine Stadtwache killen.
Ich will einfach aus dem Turm wieder raus.
Aber das Game ist verbuggt.
Okay, wir probieren nochmal was anderes.
Wenn nicht, mach ich Fast Travel und hau ab.
Okay.
Okay, das hat jetzt keiner gesehen.
Perfekt.
Outplayed.
Outplayed, würde ich sagen.
Das ist keinem aufgefallen, dass da grad irgendein Typ vom Turm gefallen ist.
Sehr gut.
Exzellent.
Da kann ich den anderen Kram auch noch looten hier.
Sieht ja keiner jetzt.
Was ist da?
Da wundert sich keiner.
Da wundert sich keiner, dass auf einmal da irgendein Typ rumläuft, der nicht durch den Checkpoint ist.
Haben wir hier irgendwas?
Silberteller.
Nein, ich klau das nicht.
Ich hab genug.
Ich hab genug Ressourcen.
Macht ja keinen Sinn.
Ich will mal checken, was passiert, wenn ich jetzt von hinten, von der anderen Seite einfach wieder an die Wache rangehe.
Mal gucken, was passiert.
Nix.
Das juckt hier einfach nicht.
Free to enter.
Okay, ganz ehrlich, Act 3 ist da noch ein bisschen verbuggt.
So, ich rede jetzt mal mit der, mit der ich mich vorhin gestritten hab.
Okay.
Jetzt, jetzt darf ich auf einmal da rein.
Sehr gut.
Ja, Act 3 ist echt noch ein bisschen unfertig, was das angeht.
Ich mein, ich hab mich vorher mit den Übels angelegt, vom Tor.
Bin da außen rumgelaufen und rede jetzt von der anderen Richtung mit denen.
Gar kein Problem.
Fällt denen überhaupt nicht auf.
So, was haben wir denn hier?
Was ist, was ist mit euch hier drinnen los?
Hi, was geht?
Mr. Wiese.
Okay.
Spezialauftrag.
Ähm, gut.
CU, hau ich wieder ab.
Ach guck mal, Fast Travel Punkt, jawoll.
Okay, was ist hier drüben? Das ist einfach mal komplett schwarz.
Wo bin ich, wo bin ich hier? Haben wir hier irgendwelche Schilder?
Schares Liebkosung.
Das klingt ein wenig...
...Gutschi-Bastheim.
Okay.
Was? Wo?
Wo?
Something over there.
Ha!
Habt ihr was gesehen?
Ach guck mal, jetzt kann ich den Typ ja sogar looten.
Ey! Leute!
Ihr wollt mir nicht erzählen, dass ihr das gesehen habt durch die Wand, dass ich den gelootet hab gerade, oder?
Ich hab nix, ihr habt nix gesehen.
CU.
Ähm, okay.
Irgendwie war das Spiel der Meinung, man hat was entdeckt gerade.
Da drüben ist etwas.
Okay.
Wo denn?
Rygors Klitsche.
Oh, das Gamer hat ein bisschen Performance-Probleme in der Stadt gerade.
Ah, aha.
Kann man hier vielleicht?
Ich teste das mal, das ist jetzt Ultra-Spell-Slot-Verschwendung.
Aber mich interessiert's einfach.
Ob hier oben irgendwas ist?
Nicht wirklich, ne?
Aber wisst ihr, ich find das mega nice, dass man überhaupt auf Dächer und so drauf kann.
Es ist schon hochgradig sinnlos, dass man hier rumstelzen kann, aber cool, dass das geht.
Ja.
Wollte es nur ausprobieren.
Übelste Spell-Slot-Verschwendung.
Ja, über Steam kann ich die FPS anzeigen, weil...
Es ist gerade ein bisschen...
Wollen wir hier hinten reingehen?
Komm, wir gehen mal durch die Fronttür.
Kläre die Morde auf. Ach, hier geht das weiter.
Hallo, was geht? Ich bin Will.
Was ist hier los?
Steam-FPS?
Wie plant man nochmal den...
In-Game-FPS?
Okay, ich geh mal in meine Steam-Settings, da muss ich euch mal kurz ausmachen, weil ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob man irgendwelche E-Mail-Adressen leaked oder so.
Steam-Settings.
Interface.
Ne, wo ist das?
In-Game.
FPS-Counter.
Ja.
Top-Left.
Okay.
Aber ich glaub, das funktioniert nicht.
Weil...
Guck mal.
Moment.
Ach doch! Nice.
Ich da... Och!
66 FPS!
Deswegen fühlt sich das auch gerade so slow an.
Ja, ja. Guck mal, in der Stadt ist ganz schön FPS-Drops angesagt.
Außerhalb hab ich 120.
Ich hab das extra... Guck mal, ich hab das extra schon limitiert hier auf...
Auf 120, dass meine CPU nicht so hoch...
...mein Lüfter nicht so hochdreht.
Wir können mal...
...gucken, ob DLSS irgendwie so viel Auswirkungen darauf hat.
Ne.
Ne, keine.
Das ist einfach nicht gut optimiert.
Ich glaub, mein Rechner ist einfach nicht stark genug für das Game.
Der ist zu alt und zu schwach.
Mein Budget-Rechner.
Leute, ich glaub, es wird mal Zeit für eine neue Kiste, oder?
Leider keinen neuen PC mehr gekauft.
So.
Was haben wir hier?
Abenteurer-Drim.
Drim, du hast deinen Pfeil irgendwie ein bisschen falsch...
...an den Bogen.
Ist doch Mist, wir sind Abenteurer!
Warum...
Warum lassen sie euch nicht rein?
Er hat ja nix.
Außer Gold.
Kann ich dir irgendwas andrehen?
Hier, komm mal in die Bilder.
Die Bilder will ich doch bestimmt haben.
Und...
...Tintenfässer auch.
Ganz essentiell.
Silber-Tortenständer auch, natürlich.
Routine.
Was hast du da?
Ne Gabel.
Ocker-Galette.
Sonst noch irgendwas zu verkaufen?
Ich hab...
Ich verkaufe nie wieder irgendwelche Briefe, nachdem ich vorhin aus Versehen die Quest-Items verkauft hab.
Geflöte, Trommel...
...Loot...
...Unterhaltsband...
Okay.
Nice.
Hat hier jemand gutes Kabelmanagement?
Im rechten Zentrum schon.
Daheim nicht.
Aber...
...hier.
Hier.
Im rechten Zentrum schon.
Daheim nicht.
Ich hab immer Hunger.
Leute, ich brauch nichts davon.
Ich hab 1500 Vorräte oder sowas übrig.
Moment.
Stand da nicht eben noch hier in der Ecke?
Hier ist anscheinend nichts weiter.
Gehen wir mal hoch.
Ne, mach ich nicht.
Ich hab mich vorhin schon mit einem angelegt.
Was ist ein Stahlwächter denn?
Den trau ich nur so weit, wie ich sie umwerfen kann.
Hier.
Truhe, Truhe...
Okay, ich klau euch nichts.
Ich klau euch nichts.
Wir sind mal nett.
Was haben wir hier drinnen?
Ah, Moment.
Das ist so...
Das ist ein Bad, oder?
Warum ist es hier abgeschlossen draußen?
Achso.
Das ist die Tür, wo ich eben davor gestanden hab.
Ja, das ist egal.
Einfach mal ein bisschen...
bisschen Moos looten.
Aufs Regal.
Was geht hier ab?
Ah, mit dem wird sich aber Astar...
Ey, die sieht aus wie...
Eben mit der Tiefen- und Schärfe
sieht die bisschen aus wie Siri.
Da, mit dem wird sich Astarion bestimmt gut verstehen.
Ja.
Astarion bestimmt gut verstehen.
Einlichkeit.
Ja, wir sollten nicht fehlschlagen.
Oh, Will!
Oh, noch mal Glück gehabt.
Close.
Knapp.
Mit denen wird sich Astarion gut verstehen.
Oh, sag es ja schon.
Okay, ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass das irgendwelche Kollegen von Astarion
sind.
Die sind ja alle so ein bisschen merkwürdig.
Ihr kennt Astarion, was ist eine schwarze Messe?
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich verraten soll, dass ich Astarion kenne.
Irgendwo, wo ihr und euer Meister ihn niemals finden werdet.
Spaltet euch die Suche, er findet euch schon früh genug.
Er hätte schon mal lieber bashen sollen.
Ich würde sagen, wir gehen mal ins Lager und fragen Astarion, was da so abgeht.
Aber ich mache nicht Astarions Quest, weil er mich als Party-Member so absolut nicht
juckt.
Ich habe die ersten 45 Minuten mit Astarion gespielt und seitdem steht er seit 100 Stunden
im Lager rum.
Okay, man kann Astarion nicht mal danach fragen.
Ja, okay, Akt 3 ist echt schon ein bisschen unfertig, weil ich meine, das ist doch das
naheliegendste ever.
Dass ich Astarion jetzt einfach frage, was war das für Dudes?
Aber gibt's nicht.
Nein, ich klaue nix, ich klaue nix, komm.
Wir müssen nicht alles sinnlos looten.
Aber guck mal, wir haben hier, hier ist noch irgendeine Quest, ist hier noch.
Kläre die Morde im Tempel auf, untersuche Freiguss, Klitsch und mache Gebrauch vom
Blumenschlüssel.
Okay, ich muss checken, ob irgendeins dieser Truhen aufgeht mit dem Schlüssel.
Kann man mit dem Dude reden und dann guckt er weg?
Nee, leider nicht.
Irgendeine dieser Truhen geht bestimmt damit auf.
Ach, guck mal, hier geht's hoch, hier geht's rauf, hier ist nur ein Balkon davor, sonst
nix.
Wisst ihr, ich finde es in solchen RPGs ja immer nice, die selbstverständlich an die
Leute in ihren Häusern rumlaufen lassen.
So, da kommen einfach so random, vier random Dudes rein, mit Pets und Vögeln und irgendwelchen
Imps und laufen durchs Wohnzimmer und legen sich da hin und gucken überall rein, oh schön,
dass ihr da seid.
Aber wie willst du es auch anders umsetzen?
Das ist der typische Fall, zwischen realistisch ist es nicht, aber halt Gameplay.
Aha, hier kommt man also durch.
Also gut, Lootbank, oh, das klingt ja mal ziemlich nach Vampir-Stelz hier, oder?
Better Story than Twilight, das geht was, okay, Tempelpläne, Wahrnehmung fehlgeschlagen
natürlich, was sonst?
Ah, wir haben irgendeinen Auftragskiller-Zeug gefunden, nein, bestimmt nicht.
Untersuche Vater Loggins Name, steht auf einer Liste von Zielen, die wir gefunden haben.
Scheint ein Test für Kultisten, wenn sie ihn bestanden haben, können sie den Tempel
des Baal betreten.
Wir sollten Ermittlerin Valeria die Liste zeigen, jawoll, das machen wir doch.
Habe ich die jetzt mitgenommen?
Wir stecken das mal ein, Tempelpläne einstecken, aufheben, alles, alles, alles grabben, hier
schlagen irgendwie, laufen irgendwelche Checks fehl, ach, Nachforschung, jetzt bräuchten
wir Witcher-Senses, Intelligenz plus 1, äh, das macht Gale, Gale ist mehr 5-Head, guck,
Gale hat plus 5, plus 4, close, ah, ha, Schlüssel, die hatte doch auch eine Truhe, mit dem Schlüssel
können wir die Truhe jetzt aufmachen, okay, hatte die nicht auch eine Truhe hier unten,
die wir jetzt aufmachen können, äh, nein, hier vielleicht, hier, alter, geh mal weg,
guck mal weg, oh, du hast überhaupt nicht hergeguckt, hau ab, ich bin immer überrascht
wie viele Leute Tagebuch in RPGs schreiben, äh, übrigens, man kann, man kann Leichen
übrigens looten, guck mal, ich habe jetzt einfach die Leiche gelootet und jetzt, zack,
zum Lager senden, nee, geht nicht, hä, aber ich kann, warte mal, zum Lager und jetzt wird
er hier in die Scheune gedampft, was, was, was, what, was regt sich das Kind jetzt so
auf, ich vermute das ist ein Bug, was Shadowheart will, was Hirn, okay, okay, was will denn
Shadowheart hier, äh, Will, rede mal kurz mit der Katze, Shadowheart, komm her, auf,
was ist hier los, oh, shit, nein, alter, ich habe das Game verbuggt, ich habe das, ich habe das
Game verbuggt, weil ich das Kind mit der Leiche erschreckt habe, geht das jetzt wieder, okay,
geht wieder, ganz toll, was lässt sich das auch so aus der Fassung bringen, wenn eine Leiche liegt,
okay, das haben wir gelootet, jetzt können wir hier oben den Rest, der Typ ist weg, Leute,
der Typ ist weg, wir können einfach jetzt alles looten, guck mal, ob da was Gescheites drin ist,
wahrscheinlich nicht, ach komm, scheiß drauf, wir looten jetzt hier nicht alles, so, also,
das hätten wir jetzt geklärt und jetzt müssen wir zurück in den Tempel und mit dem Typ reden,
der die Morde aufklären will, Will, du bist der Charismatischste, lauf mal vor, Moment, Moment,
wo ist der Tempel, der Tempel ist hier oben irgendwo, ja, hier ist der Tempel, da muss ich hin,
ja, irgendwo, da, da ist der Tempel, auf, Game, lauf mal ein bisschen schneller, irgendwo hier,
wo ist denn der Typ, mit dem ich reden muss, hier ist die Mordwaffe, ich habe sie im geheimen Tunnel
unter dem Tempel gefunden, ich suche noch, wo wird ihr beginnen,
ja, wo ist denn der Typ, mit dem ich reden soll,
ich muss zu Schares Liebkosung, okay, dahin muss ich, hier, dachte ich muss zurück zum Tempel,
okay, warte, ich muss mal nebenbei was futtern, ich habe übelst Hunger, warte mal,
so, wir da,
Ja, anscheinend.
Das ist ein Vergnügen.
Komm, um deinen Respekt vor der echten Frau des Hauses zu bezahlen.
Siehst du?
Was für ein kluger Kreatur du bist.
Es ist dein glücklicher Tag.
Ich erhalte zu dieser Zeit Komplimente.
Und du bist herzlich willkommen, um ein Angebot zu machen.
Ich würde sagen, versuche die Katze zu streichen, aber das will sie wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ich, ich save mal.
Das dachte ich mir.
Deswegen.
Da wird einmal, also für die Katze wird auch gesave scammt.
Um deinen Respekt vor der echten Frau des Hauses zu bezahlen.
Es ist dein glücklicher Tag.
Ich erhalte zu dieser Zeit Komplimente.
Und du bist herzlich willkommen, um ein Angebot zu machen.
Oh, du bist ziemlich korrekt.
Ich bezeichne sie als eine meiner schönsten Fähigkeiten.
Die ungewaschen Rabblen, die dieses Ergebnis befreien,
haben viel zu lernen von deiner Verwirrung.
Und ich muss ihre Feuern allein leiden.
Aber sie sagen, dass ein Teil des Bedürfnisses eine Hälfte des Bedürfnisses ist.
Hörst du nicht von hier aus?
Sie sprechen über den neuen Topkatz in der kriminellen Untersuchung für dich selbst.
Für sie persönlich,
Der eine wascht nie und verurteilt sich stattdessen mit Rosenöl,
während der Andere seinen Trinken nicht hält.
Der Drau, zwei unserer populärsten Kortisanten.
Eine Nacht mit ihnen scheint relativ lebensverändernd zu sein.
Wenn du es dir leisten kannst.
Das sind unsere Brüder.
Wenn man sich in den Thronen der Klienten anschaut,
sind die meisten der Städte so schrecklich, wie sie sind.
Das ist eher ein Witz.
Er trainiert wundervoll, aber...
Jetzt!
Da ist ein Gesicht, das ich erinnern würde, wenn ich es gesehen hätte.
Willkommen bei Charest's Caress.
Was können Huts für dich tun, Fremder?
Ich glaube, du hast Lust auf Eier.
Oder vielleicht...
Ach, vergiss es.
Mein neuer Brot könnte dir in den Augen eines Zuschauer fallen.
Oder du kannst dich auf die Zunge schlagen.
Oder dich aus dem Kühlschrank schlagen.
Keine Ahnung, bis der erste Drop.
Du hast es geschafft.
Will, du kannst es.
Das ist ein Witz.
Ich glaube, du hast Lust auf Eier.
Oder vielleicht...
Ach, vergiss es.
Mein neuer Brot könnte dir in den Augen eines Zuschauer fallen.
Oder du kannst dich aus dem Kühlschrank schlagen.
Das ist ein Witz.
Also, komm nicht zu mir, wenn deine großen Beine fallen oder deine Zunge in einem Knoten klingelt.
Charest's Caress.
Hol die Aufmerksamkeit, die du willst, und vermeid die Aufmerksamkeit, die du nicht hast.
Das ist meine Sache. Aber...
Ähm, was macht das?
Haut auch nüchterner sofort um.
Das war's für Kallak, die mag sowas.
Ein trauriger Reisender, verbrannt und verbrannt.
Du kommst für Erholung, nicht für Decadenz.
Ein kaltes Eis, doch die Augen sind heiß.
Oh ja, ich kenne deinen Glück.
Ein stabiler Dwarf, ein Leather Whip.
Sie gibt, du bekommst.
Schatz, bist du bluschig?
Es gibt keine Schande in Freude, sogar weniger, wenn die Freude Schmerz ist.
Es ist Fionn, die du suchst, unsere steile Bibliothek.
Sie ist heute nicht hier.
Trotzdem, deine Zahlen müssen warten.
Nun, wir haben uns aufgeregt, deinen Jungen zu füllen.
Ein Trick für einen, ein Paar Schmerz für den anderen.
Entwickle deinen Schmerz.
Ich gebe es dir, Gratis!
Gib es ihm Gratis!
Du bist ein Schlampe!
Ich habe noch eine Schüssel geöffnet.
Du bist ein Bluthahn!
Ich erkenne das Gesicht.
Du hast mit Janice gesprochen, nachdem ich das Tempel verlassen habe.
Ich wette, sie hat dich auf etwas aufgesetzt.
Warum solltet ihr Busybodies aufhören, eine perfekte Nacht zu verbringen?
Ich kenne das Gesicht.
Ihr erinnert mich an D'Valla.
Wenn ihr meine Erklärungen enttäuscht, was habt ihr gefunden?
Du sagst, dass mehr als eine Person in Baldurs Gate getötet wurde?
Du musst etwas Besseres haben.
Ich brauche harte Beweise und einen Motiv.
Warum würde jemand anderes Rorgan töten?
Wie können wir sicher sein, dass es nicht Rilgor war?
Das ist eine große Entdeckung.
Die Entdeckung sagt mir nicht alles. Warum war Rorgan tötet?
Ich brauche Beweise.
Wenn jemand anderes Rorgan getötet hat, möchte ich, dass du mir sagst, warum sie es getan haben.
Wirklich? Du auch?
D'Valla hat schon seit Monaten über Baal gerufen.
Sie hat eine Ahnung von einem Experten.
Ich dachte, es seien nur ein paar Geheimdienste.
Aber sie hat sich ungewöhnlich darauf geäußert.
Auch für sie.
Okay, was ist deine Theorie?
Was will er heute eigentlich sagen?
Was wartet ihr?
Ihr habt eine verdammte Geheimdienste zu verkaufen.
Geht!
Du siehst aus wie jemand, der seine Seele füttern muss.
Willst du etwas Kunst kaufen?
Komm nicht wieder!
Bis bald!